[Music]
hello everybody and welcome back to
frenemies
episode number two 200 billion i don't
even know we're just in it now we're
just killing it
i feel like i haven't seen you in so
long i missed you this week oh thank you
that's nice i do sometimes i see what
you're doing i'm like oh i get like fomo
like it seems like you're having so much
fun in life and i'm like oh i was just
really like what what was i doing it was
so fun
well it was just the gubernatorial
aquarium it was oh yeah it was private i
don't know if you did you post about it
maybe you post about it
i don't think so i saw on whatsapp and i
was like they look like they're having
so much fun oh yeah it was fun it was
just
it was just me elaine grandma yeah it
was fun though theodore had a lot of fun
that's the first time we've gone out
with him you know since the pandemic
started the teeth are making it
difficult for me
i like it i'll see how long i can last
now yeah you look like you like lost
some weight in your face
really yeah are you saying that because
the mask you get cheekbones i see your
cheekbones oh you're just saying it
because of my mask
dude i feel like such a chad in this
mask
like it'd be funny if we didn't even
talk about it but sponsored today by
oh yeah we have three sponsors today bro
oh my god dude i feel like
let's just let's just i want
[Applause]
i'm giving you the bob do you have your
consent i offered the book okay
i'm nervous okay making a big deal out
of the whole wrestling i got i got
ripped in the comments well hold on no i
i never hold on i didn't actually say
the sponsors
thank you to quip me undies and upstart
friend of me is coming up baby we got
three spots let's [ __ ] down
moses wears me undie all the time for
real you must i think he got him from
you guys i think you guys gave him my
undies one time
you liked me undies all the time where's
them save it for the copier donuts okay
let's get let's stop all right um i saw
you made a tick tock saying i was your
best friend
yeah isn't that our thing we're best
friends you said i was your best friend
one time
you said that once in a tech talk so i
was like oh my god we're best friends
you said it first
oh yeah you did say it first otherwise i
would never oh okay you felt good
i was so excited i was like wow yeah i
thought it was nice that you did that
yeah and even on i did a podcast last
week and they're like who would you
rather be with like
bobby lee or ethan and i'm like ethan
because he's my bestie
well what the [ __ ] why would you even
consider bobby lee it's like you haven't
like are you kidding me like oh that's
like a tough question
that's like would you rather be with
some random dude you just met today or
ethan like i'm sorry who am i
but i knew bobby before he didn't
remember me but
so awkward when someone doesn't remember
you and you're like no we met like five
times
really when did you make bobby the
eminem music video oh and he's like
don't remember it i don't think it's
kind of a big deal back then i mean he's
got a big shot
probably right anyways um
can i can i plug teddy fresh real fast
yeah but i'm gonna need like three weeks
at the end of may to promote sad boy
you promote whatever i tell you hey you
got the floor you promote whatever you
want girl and i'll be your biggest
cheerleader no no i know also um
happy ramadan right it's ramadan a b
and lena two of our employees are
celebrating it seems brutal
yeah you can't eat till like eight
o'clock or you can't drink that's the
most brutal no drinking water
all of my security guards in my old
house were on ramadan when they started
and they would like always be like i'm
about to faint
oh my god yeah and they're like no it's
ramadan i'm like what they can have
water
yeah that's crazy i don't like that
that's crazy
i don't think av wasn't like that muslim
i didn't either
honestly but they're doing the ramadan
god bless them you know
good with uh they're good with god
what can i say or is it allah it's the
same god actually
the jews the christians and the muslims
it's the same god
is it okay i think they're all the same
god i think buddha's god
i think they're all the same no but
literally they are the same god i mean
like
from the books and everything but you
don't even believe in god so what that
means
i'm just telling you like historically
like biblically or whatever it's all the
same
right well muhammad was a prophet he's
not god
hmm we don't say
we don't say anything bad about muhammad
here i have my old strip club manager's
name was muhammad and he'd always go
hey ted it's me moe mohammed that's how
you'd call me and i'd be like
anyways it was a bad experience but i
won't
share it you already shared it what else
you feel like you want to know that
godfather is in van nuys shout out if
you're still working there
shout out to you know how would he be
named after a god but he's like
working a strip club can i tell you
something interesting muhammad
if i'm not mistaken and i am mistaken
about many things so
but i'm pretty sure i'm right about this
and dan you can fact-check me mohammed
is the most popular name in the world
wow so there you go there's a lot of
mohammed's out there
can i name my kid muhammad or would that
be cultural appropriation
you probably can i don't know why you
would do that why would i like the name
muhammad
i find i would find that odd i think i'm
like muhammad ali when i think of
muhammad you do
are you wait you got you you gotta go
with the jewish name right now you're
going with the arab name
i want to be everything or muslim name
i'm sorry triple my chances of getting
to heaven
so name them like like uh mohammed
just take everything eat socks mohammed
forget about it with an italian and
maybe something like chinese name in
there too
like something like buddha hot
i don't know what the [ __ ] do i know
you're bringing up all this great [ __ ]
i'm not prepared to talk about chinese
names
i love ramadan i wish i could support
you and that honestly because i just
can't
not eat for i need to eat well there's
um one of these jewish holidays you're
supposed to fast
and i always thought it was just food
because my
my family's just i'm gonna take these
off too much for you
you were doing good i was surprised but
doesn't it sound funny a little bit
it's not that pleasant to listen to it
yeah yeah i think it's a good call
oh no you can pop them back in there
are you auditioning for the mask are
they looking the master sequel
i'm gonna play uncle fester i'm gonna
play the mask i'm everything yeah i was
saying i was like
would you actually like yeah i would ask
so anyone who has a part for ethan he
said he would act
we'll take it i've got offered a few
parts really but they always
they always say uh never mind we don't
need you like what kind of movies like
independent not like major parts just
like little cameo
stupid crap that's dope though but i
never did it
yeah i don't get offered for movie roles
maybe we can be in like
why don't we write our own movies like
talk to you guys yeah
we should do the math like body positive
edition because i do not look like
cameron diaz she was so skinny my arm
sounds like a fat porn version of the
mask
the fat max xxx you know i'm not fat but
no they did a sequel of the mask it was
awful remember jamie kennedy he did son
of the mask oh my god
so bad i didn't watch that it was awful
okay so real fast i'm gonna blast you
this teddy fresh new collection and
restocks
this thursday what's this thursday uh
the 20 something
what is this thursday because i get paid
wait it's the 22nd that's only in two
days that can't be
no today's the 19th yeah
today's monday tuesday wednesday oh
you're right oh my god it's thursday you
guys did the math
tuesday for them though unless you're a
member then it's monday oh my god it's
so confusing anyway the beanies
we love the beanies this guy loves it
more beanies and dope models thank you i
like how like
they're all unique we try really hard to
find interesting models he's hard
he looks good though he's rocking it
there's a new photo i love that it looks
like charlie sheen can you guys see
that yeah i like that shirt a lot oh my
god i want that when can i get it
you want it what size you want double xl
okay sure because i was gonna wear the
black hoodie guys sent me but it was an
xl
and i don't know can you um can you
write to ela to reser you want there's
just black and like uh pink i like the
black
looks like i don't know if like charlie
she's a good thing but it reminds me of
charlie sheen maybe that's
we got the x-ray teddy bear we got this
shirt that i was wearing the other day
it's really nice
this hoodie is my favorite ever it's a
restock
a new camp shirt oh there's more sorry
uh we're almost done here this is my
favorite hoodie we've ever made the baby
one
yeah that's the baby one who famously
wore that one's being restocked
beanie shirts this is the shirt i made
it says
it says sleep work or sorry is it sleep
eat work die oh morbid
how about why don't you make you as a
bear since i keep telling you look at a
bear can we be goldilocks on the three
bears can we do that collection oh my
god wait oh i thought you meant for
dress-up
no for well that but for teddy brush
what do you mean
like in what way like put you as the
little bear like you look like an ethan
bear
with a little podcast microphone yeah
yeah yeah you'd be the bear with your
face
somebody listening if you want to make
that i'll look at it
no guarantees well you know how people
always say oh make a merchant then they
don't pay them
it's like hey i'm not making any
guarantees if you want to make that
straight up you're probably not going to
get paid or even acknowledge but i don't
know what to tell you
but if i do use it obviously you know i
don't know what to say have you done
that before have you used have you
commissioned people before that we're
like fans
yeah yeah yeah we do it all the time
really but we just you have to just make
sure to pay them or even if you don't
use it you have to pay them
so anyway um that's a teddy fresh this
thursday and follow us on teddyfish on
instagram to know when it's dropping
thank you
trisha how was your weekend it was great
thank you
that was great i feel like we're on a
talk show right now why do i feel that
way because i'm all boofed up maybe
that's it like ryan and kelly during
halloween week
right now i love it we probably get more
views from ryan kellen
ryan and kellen kelly ryan and kellen
i don't know what is their viewership
dan who cares about ryan secrets he's
like
so boring i literally can't stand him
i like ryan seacrest but i think he's
not like his time has passed
he was good on american idol like my
brother or my sister my dad were like
obsessed with him which is weird and
they always go
see chris oh like they loved that and i
was like
you're so opposite of your dad and
brother it's so weird you're like
related to them like i love them but
they're just like so opposite of you i
feel
like that's a compliment i take that as
a but do you feel sad about it or you
don't care
nah i'm over the trauma of my childhood
okay we won't bring it out
it's not it's not like deep crazy trauma
it's just like uh
my dad wasn't my dad didn't play catch
with me kind of [ __ ]
yeah he didn't fit in not that big of a
deal yeah well look at you now
look at me now smoking baby
what if you get cast in the next mask
i'm gonna be so jealous
that's not happening i'm manifesting
that for you the way i manifest like
zohan for moses
i'm gonna be looking cold i'm going to
have nobody casting me i'm trying
no you you manifested you onto snl and
me stuck here in the podcast
that's what you originally manifested
you move up my ass stays right here
never because frenemies gave me like
that's why people like me now because in
front of me so like this is
no matter where i go i'll remember where
yeah right you would leave me at the
[ __ ] trenches taking grenades and
mustard gas as your ass was
hosting snl i told you you could be on
for the arm bit
to cut your arm off oh right right yeah
can i come on at the end and just be
like hey guys
when they're all balanced yeah clapping
yeah if they let me
it's inappropriate do you think to be
honest no you could
but i feel like the musical guest will
be next to me and then i kind of want
pete davidson next to me so maybe you're
next to pete davidson
but then so yeah so i i won't come on
then because
there's just no space for me on that
stage just being friends next to like
kyle mooney back bennett
why am i there why am i there they don't
even know who i am
that's where the jewish people are am i
not supposed to say that
is that offensive oh you want to put all
the jews in the ghetto now
and one you want to put a special part
of this of the stage just for the jews
they're jokes i say it with peace and
love i hope people know because by the
way
after the last time he corrected me for
being like not politically grateful
people tons of jewish people were like
no we get that you love us like we love
it we love when you talk about jewish
people because that's so exciting like
you're bringing like spotlights on the
jewish people like i didn't get
spotlights on jewish people what kind of
jews says that just don't want spotlight
like give love to jewish people and
you're like that's weird but people are
like no most people like hate on us so
you're like oh i love
jewish people i don't think anyone said
that to you
i show most all the time i get emails
you know who wrote them to you
you know who wrote them to you moses
moses yeah okay whatever everyone's
writing moses fan mail about how great
your jewish comments are all right let's
start i have a ton of [ __ ] i want to
talk
about
that's one other thing with
manifestation benefits the [ __ ] out of
it okay so sadly 0005 has another album
coming out soon and i wrote a song
about jack black and how he was like the
original body positive king
and i really would love like a feature
jack
if you're listening i would love for you
like because you're so musical and so
talented and you give like chubby people
inspiration like me to be sexy and
chubby and he was trending this week
because of the sexy and chubby quote
from school of rock which i put on my
tick tock so i think i had a little bit
of something to do with it i know he's
famous because we watched jumanji we've
been like obsessed with him shallow hell
not the best move but you can have your
redemption
great i know people are like angry about
like how but like as a kid i
loved that movie of course you would
cause you are fear of fat people you
hate i was a young
everybody loved that film when it came
out it's just now that
everyone's revising history like oh that
movie was [ __ ] up
everybody knew that movie was a banger
when it came out
fat phobic people he ended up with the
fat chick he was like i love this fatty
at the end no he kissed the wrong fat
person he's like okay i'm gonna love her
now so he just kissed a different fat
person as if all fat people look alive
it was such a good movie
and they portrayed her as breaking not
one table but like a booth she breaks a
little booth in the movie look if you go
back to the 1920s you know
[ __ ] was weird then too and they just
put your hair is like just stuffing your
face like anywhere she goes oh i need to
get some food she's just always stuffing
listen it was [ __ ] up the movie in
retrospect is extremely [ __ ] up so why
are you on
board with me it was funny it was great
i loved it and then you have jason's
outro in a fat suit jack black jason
alexander
and the only way that she can show her
inner beauty is by being skinny
that's how they portray someone being
beautiful
every every person no i know it's it's
super [ __ ] up but it's a great movie
all the hot girls once they became like
they could see their inner beauty they
were
fat they were fat originally but then
they had to become supermodels how else
are you supposed to convey their inner
beauty he's attracted to them
fat girl that's funny it means fat girls
aren't attractive
that's what i'm saying like dan you've
seen that movie
i actually never did what i never saw it
it's so offensive no it's so i remember
everything i just had to look it up it
got
it has a 50 on rotten tomatoes dude i
was young
i thought it was so funny you know that
was during jack black's like height
i don't know why people are just getting
on the jack black train i found that so
bizarre like
jack black train again can i just say
that i think i started it okay i'll give
you credit
i look like jackpot i used to not like
it when i was little because i looked
like him
look hold on let me keep track you look
like samuel jackson
you look like jack black who else i look
like i think jack walks my doppelganger
no who else was that it was um
oh someone told me billy joel one time
oh
don't oh what is that joe rogan over
here not you billy joel comparison
that's not a flattering well
we shouldn't body chain billy dull or or
look shame him
so am i not okay okay so can i not
acknowledge
like anybody's physical attributes
we should as people as a society i think
there's other things you can go for
people without having to be like oh
there's it's really funny that's a
problem but when when
um okay here's an example like i was
talking about joe rogan on the podcast
i missed that whole segment i totally
skipped i didn't watch it in response to
the whole thing between you and him it
was
you responding to his clip and i was
like
i was saying how i can't be too critical
on joke because i said worse things
about you when i first met you right
and i was talking about how i've evolved
so much since then and i would
never say that stuff about you now but
then
people were like well you body shamed
joe rogan in that same clip so i was
like
that made me think like that is
interesting should i do i need to stop
commenting on men's physical appearances
if they're like
a p word like james charles if they're
like evil then we can drag him to hell
drag him
i think if it's like not so evil because
a lot of people were calling him like
you know it says he looks like an egg or
like so my point is that joe rogan
is like objectively hilarious looking
he's conventionally energy like pull up
like that picture of him no i wouldn't
say he's unattractive i wouldn't say
that i would
well but i'm conventionally undertaken
no he's jacked he's probably got a
he's probably got a [ __ ] like a beer can
he's not no
that's not true really short but thick
no not thick
especially if he does allegedly if he's
doing steroids or something to help him
like those always have the little
oh you think he's gonna lie always
always jill rogan's got a little one you
heard it here from trisha paytas i mean
it just radiates small to energy the way
he was like
oh you can keep it it's like okay isn't
that funny because he's all about the
alpha brain yeah he radiates small dick
energy so no because you know i said
this before in the channel say it again
if a guy has to go out of his way to say
how unattractive you are there's
something like deep rooted there because
if i was truly unattractive like
i don't know who's like on a track but
like a really ugly troll or something
you wouldn't say that to someone who's
disgusting right by whatever your
standard is whether that's a big fat
person or whatever
so there's something like deep rooted
with people because it happens with
who was it recently that just oh like
the bar stool people it's always like
deep rooted something
even like when you do the video me i'm
like there's something deeper because
like i'm not
disgusting i don't look like a corpse
you know what i mean so i don't think
there was something i was just trying to
be funny but it was it was at times
insensitive
because my my whole step my mistake was
not knowing you before i made that
because
yeah you are very upfront about like
how you look without makeup and the
filters and all that so that's where i
made the mistake
whereas i was like oh these people are
putting on this false perception
of of beauty and they're harmful to
society people like the kardashians
and so that's why i was like i feel
justified in making fun of their parents
a little bit like that
you know what i mean yeah i think it's
also like that time is different i think
now like
today i don't know if we need to like
make it i feel so um
i think you're right but i also and i
have to acknowledge
a little bit of of i don't know if it's
not misogyny but there's some
like uh where i feel like it's okay to
make fun of joe's appearance
but not yours there's something there
for sure damn what do you make of that
what's your insight well i mean
joe had just made a disparaging mark
about somebody's appearance i feel like
that opened him
up to a little bit of commentary true
thank you dan thank you thank you with
peace and love
that's a good one i think if i call
someone fat they'd be like um trisha
you're not skinny you know so maybe
the way it was i think okay also let's
say like chloe
he like four nine i mean like he's like
a little oompa loopa
he's like a jacked ooh balloon she can't
shame men that's like way shaming women
that's like uh
okay right i know i know i'm so confused
i'm trying to do better i'm just so
confused because he
really looks like a japanese blows you
can go for right like you could be like
you
you hosted fear factor you know you
could always i love that fair factor
i love fairfax that's the only time he
was relevant was like in the 90s
he's huge what do you think dude your
husband your fiance is a huge show rogan
not anymore
uh-oh i'm just kidding can i just still
listen to joe
youtube really you didn't fall into
spotify no
no that's he disappeared so can i just
say i actually like
sorry because i wasn't like super
offended but it gave me such a good
opportunity
oh yeah i would have taken that too yeah
i was like when i woke up
like joe rogan goes off on youtube i was
kind of proud i was like oh yeah trisha
it's all it's not a question of if it's
a question of how long the video is
going to be
and they couldn't and i was your remark
oh look at trish appealing i did see
that part or my mom told me that you
were talking about my peeling wow you
weren't feeling well i just said i
didn't say like oh look at her she's
like
pointed out the obvious that was
obviously possible what did i do
i didn't do anything anyways i didn't
want to make it because i was peeling
and i was burnt and everything like that
but i was like you know what i need to
jump on this because i was like no you
did it i did i was like dude i did the
same thing with
dave pork boy mentioned me on the bff
and i made like a whole podcast about
him
yeah well the thing is i was like you
know what you gotta take the
uh you gotta take the opening well one
thing moza said about george oh anytime
someone's on it like their books go
number one
my only fans went blasted
like i got so many new people i would
say ten thousand new people
i know ten thousand new people you got
ten thousand new people
at five dollars a month what are you
doing yeah it was crazy because that
girl what was her name
ali makovsky shout out to her she's like
i love trish on
oh my god she was like so nice she was
sorry and she was plugging your only
fans like big time
she's savage holy [ __ ] so you know what
i did then after she plugged in like all
those new people she said i was a savage
on there so i took all my highlights
from all my sex tapes that i made sorry
moses but like all my
highlights and i like packaged them into
one like you guys want to see all my sex
tapes one time
i'm trying not to like sell the sex
tapes anymore because like i'm in the
relationship
well moses i mean it's already been
reported right yeah it's out there it's
whatever yeah he's done you gotta get
paid girl
yeah and honestly
shout out to joe rosa genuinely i was
like oh this is like amazing
actually more shout out to the girl yeah
ali makowsky but also shout out to joel
cause he he kind of like kept it going
like
the guy was being like a dan he was
being a hater the producer was being so
damn like oh
this girl and i was just like i was like
why are you he's like do you know who
she is and jamie was like
i hate that i do i was like come on dude
but dan didn't want me as a guest either
the first time i don't know what it is
about
guys they're just immediately like not
trish
which is great that's true and daniel's
that we don't hate dan for that
no no don't tell him he was just
offering counsel and um
to the end wow well good for you i'm so
happy for you yeah no and it wasn't like
it could have been worse it's not like
he's like
she's [ __ ] no it was yeah but in my
head i think he was probably thinking
he wanted to say that you could tell he
said i'd pass on that he wanted to say
more but he he held his song
yeah yeah which is good i mean that
shows progress is gonna do you that's
why i don't want you to do keto because
then you're gonna end up like joe rogan
just out of his [ __ ] head having
people bought ufos because i researched
him a little bit and he does like people
talk about like he
believes like ufo [ __ ] and stuff like
that i don't know i know nothing about
him other than the fear factor stunt but
yeah he was on a show too like a radio
show like what was it
news radio awful on that show too just
so you could go for
that kind of stuff he's just no anyway
he basically just said oh i'd pass on
that and then you made a eight minute
video i was like let's [ __ ] go
yeah yeah so you're having a good month
on only fans yeah nice and i never
promote it anymore like
that's why i was surprised she said it
because i rarely promote we talk about
it here all the time
do we not really though not like oh
onlytrish.com only five dollars like
nothing you just did
oops no and that was my time to promote
it because
i was getting new followers like i don't
care if you promote it go for it get
that paper boop i don't really care
about it
i like it i make content for it but are
you going to squirt for your new
audience
oh yeah i have a whole squirting
compilation that i'm putting on sale for
them and everything
how much does a swearing compilation
cost like five dollars oh that's a good
deal for all my massive squirts
and massive squirts do you have small
squirts yeah sometimes they're like a
rupture and sometimes they're just like
what's the cleanup process like you do
it outside so no cleanup it dries up
oh you just squirt outside i used to do
it in my bed and it was kind of like a
lot
but did you go to bed at night it was
still wet yeah yeah
yeah it was gross that's horrible yeah
for sure do you ever sleep in squirt
moses
no we don't get to monetize let's not
get to monetize on this episode or like
have it under for review so let's go on
from our
maybe we call it water works or water
sports or something when we talk about
water works
i think they're called water supply you
could say squirt i don't think we got in
trouble for that
we'll just keep it moving but would you
consider yourself a squirt
queen i i don't know i don't think i
wonder if there's like a world record
for the longest or most volume squirt
like there should be some possibilities
i have a lot that comes out of me people
like wow do you think you would be able
to compete in such a contest like
show yeah if like howard stern was still
that person he'd probably have one of
those competitions and i'd be honest
squirting contest
anyways thank you for all the new people
signing ali and i love when girls sign
up there's so many girls that are just
like yeah i love churches only fans i
think that's dope
i was kind of surprised that she was
like just watching it for content
i'm always shocked anybody watching
because i figured this just do
like dudes jerking off but yeah she was
like no i love watching it for the
content i was like wow
and she gave the good plug so she
uploads it she uploads daily and i do i
try and keep it up maybe i should make
an only fan
i told you this you should because it's
just the homies just the homies will
watch for the content
just follow me
what sign up homies it's not gay ethan
onlyfans.com
ethan or even no home okay if they want
to
it can be gay but like hey it's all good
it's just content
you're like a daddy bear in that world
you're like yeah that's you
i'm saying the gay culture would call
you like a daddy bear i don't want to be
a daddy bear
i think you would do a really good not
only fancy i want to be a twink
you can't be that you could be a twunk
what's a twunk
it's like a it's like tyler oakley wait
isn't he a twink a former twink but when
you're old he gained the low one no no
no no oh
when you're older you're
i'll never be a tweet again
okay so first of all you want to talk
about the wrestling situation
you know jack black so can you just like
oh i was gonna say i think there might
be a chance that you might actually may
be able to get him
i don't know if he would like me because
i feel like sometimes those kind of
people don't know he's very family
friendly like his whole
so maybe um but tenacious d is not super
family friendly
not at all yeah no no no but like it's
not family
but it's not controversial you know what
i mean i'm not anymore people are like
we're we're here for trish 2.0 like i'm
trying to be good in this world i really
am trying
i go to therapy literally like three
times a week i try so freaking hard to
be like
good and like show that i'm good like i
just i really want to do good i'm trying
to adopt kids and that's like not
happening i'm trying to like help
everybody let me see if i can get let me
see if i can talk to jack black
okay even if he doesn't want to do a
collab maybe we could do a competition
like school of rock where we take some
kids
and we teach them like we'd be in a band
with them and he can like that sounds
like a lot more work
i don't see that happening maybe we
could do this thing where he raises me
and pretends he's my dad for a year
no but i have a song and it's called
jack [ __ ] it's a really good song
cause it's about body positivity and i
feel like he has such a good feature on
it
like i know it's like a long shot but
hey i'm shooting my shot with people
these days you know it might work i
actually think he might it might work
i just think we're such a good because
he's still like me i'm trying to reach
out
because you know what my favorite line
of school of rock and i love it i'm
gonna like turn into it's a quote in my
like song because it's so good
the chubby girl goes to him um or it's a
child who's like obsessed with her
weight she's not even whatever
and he she goes she goes oh he goes well
i'm fat and i'm chubby i'm sexy and i'm
chubby and she goes why don't you on a
diet and he's like because
i like to eat is that such a crime and i
was like yes
like when people were like why don't you
just go on a diet or get life
no it's better if you do this this is
what i do like wow that feels really
good yeah right it's like this like
tingles and like asmr like the tapping
let me hear some taps um
or on this
what do you guys get up to with these
claws huh what do you guys get up to
nothing he won't let me near him i try
and cup for him because i love i love
cupping him that's my favorite thing and
he won't let me do that you want letter
with the nails really
i think you look scary though i feel
like you'd be stabbing yourself all the
time they're not bad how do you wipe
your ass
um toilet mitts like you you lit it up
and then you softened i feel like you
couldn't get a deep wipe with that
you're not gonna get a deep one yeah oh
you have a shitty [ __ ] right now
a little bit it sounds like you're okay
we have a good day at the house
so it sounds like church has a little
bit of a shitty [ __ ] oh my god what
is with this episode it's so
cool we're family friendly we're trying
to get jack black hold on uh
we're just we're just about at 30. we
shouldn't have three minutes we are
having so much fun tonight
is it 30 minutes already we're in
costume oh my god
costume makes everything so fun by the
way my ears are totally covered so i'm
just partially deaf i'm trying to talk
louder
yeah just so that people know like my
ears are literally covered in foam yeah
so i was like projecting a little thank
you but i feel like it was good energy
you're shouting at me but it's good
energy all right should we do the ad
reads
yeah before we start okay we'll be right
back
okay cool
well thank you to quip for sponsoring us
two hooligans
thank you for sponsoring also adding the
competition element to our show it can't
be in front of me without competing
and we are having a competition with
quip toothbrushes i'm team
pink and ethan's team black and purchase
these toothbrushes to help charity and
help me win
okay so let me explain it's a vibrating
tube no
it's a vibrating toothbrush no it's the
greatest freaking invention
that's come around in the last 20 years
the vibrating brush in a tube
it's a it's a vibrating toothbrush with
this powerful battery it doesn't need to
be
recharged all the time it's like you get
a comparable vibrating toothbrush costs
like a bajillion dollars from all these
main
all these lame-o brands quip gives it to
you
at an affordable price they start
off what do they use they start off
really like on a low end
um the price is really good they've got
it tells you
so it times it you turn on the timer and
then every 30 seconds
it vibrates so you know to switch
quadrants boom boom boom two minutes
total brush
and it's lightweight other toothbrushes
are so heavy like this this is nice and
lightweight
and have sensitive sonic vibrations so
here's the deal we got a special thing
going on here with them
uh well let me tell you about first
third thing you can earn rewards just by
brushing your teeth with the frenemies
themed electric toothbrushes
we are competing also to raise money and
charity as tricia said
the quip smart electric toothbrush
rewards you for good brushing habits
all you have to do is pair with your
quip app using bluetooth
and you earn points for brushing well if
you brush for two minutes evenly twice a
day you earn more points
points can be redeemed for rewards if
like target e-cards or even free
equipped
brush head refills the quip smart brush
comes in all pink or all black and it's
got
the vibrations on a two minute timer and
pulses every 30 seconds i already said
that because i
am a fan of quit and it automatically
delivers brush heads to your door every
three months
for just five dollars with free shipping
worldwide so you can stay fresh clean
yeah bye you gotta love it and you can
get ten dollars on your quip
electric toothbrush set with code peace
and love at gekwip.com
plus okay here's the deal we're
competing to raise money for charity
for everyone that buys trisha's all pink
whip
ten dollars will be donated to trish's
non-profit choice the national center
for transgender equality
and not to be shown up by trisha i will
be donating ten dollars for everyone
that gets black which is obviously
superior color there's just so much
versatility with black have you ever
owned a black toothbrush no it's awesome
have you ever had a pink toothbrush
even more awesome i think you're gonna
win you win everything
ah thank you i think you're going to
crush me everyone's a winner though here
because you get the toothbrush
anyway excuse me why are you weaponizing
the quiz
i'm not a toothbrush not a missile um
so for every for every purchase of the
ethan toothbrush
ten dollars will be going to the trevor
project which also
goes to help lgbtq community we love it
who do you think will raise the most
money trisha
confident and the black side i just i
think people are going to like the pink
the pink is and it goes perfect it's so
it's so amazing i've never
i like love this this is so go to
g-e-t-q-u-y-p dot com
and use code peace and love to get 10
off
the all pink and r or all black smart
brush and
quip will donate ten dollars for each
purchase that's really quite
awesome of them i have to say that's get
quipped.com
with code peace and love with peace and
love peace and love
peace and love this is so cool oh terms
apply
terms of play me
undies is changing the game of underwear
let's face it
the undies you're wearing right now
probably 10 years old
probably frank probably has holes in it
and you bought it from like macy's or
some place like that and all the
underwear is the same there's no
elevated underwear that's where me
undies comes in they got the softest
fabric in the game
this is breathable flexible
lovable this is the game baby it's made
from some like ins
some like space age technology called
micro modal it's like some crazy ass
uh fabric but it feels soft i like the
crazy prince it has dumplings on it
dumplings i love a dumpling underwear
dumpling in a dumpling yeah
you should be eating dumplings for your
photo for this are you getting a photo
on these dumplings
they also go up to 4xl which is crazy
very positive
yeah 4xl um i'm reaching the upper end
of that so we might need more 4xl
i could try yeah so anyway that's why me
undies is not only sustainable
breathable and soft as heck
but they give you all kinds of styles to
choose from briefs
me undies offers the classic colors to
ridiculous prints it's all so you can
fully express yourself in your own
unique way
they're also available in xs to 4xl for
the big boys and girls out there in the
crowd we love
we love the fatties and for the
non-binary the non-genders
oh and also if you don't have a gender
you still will fit in the forex cell
yeah
regardless of your underwear is for you
too
do we love the fatties can i say that
yeah the fatties are coming for the
forex
we already yeah yeah they're coming for
you they're coming for that 4xl
never leave your couch again with me
andy's membership a monthly subscription
that sends new pairs right to your door
and with sites site-wide savings and
exclusive sales you'll automatically pay
less for everything
never do laundry again with that
subscription just throw them out one
time
me and this has a great do you really
yeah i just want you underwear more than
once no it wasn't telling you we just
opened up new underwear all the time
you don't wear washed underwear seems
wasteful it seems like a lot
yeah don't do that with these these are
oh no nevermind this you could wear at
least twice
right if i'm getting a subscription
every month who cares
okay you guys want to offer here it
comes mendeus has a great offer for our
listeners for any first time purchase
you get 15
off and free shipping here's the deal
though problem free philosophy says if
you're not satisfied with any product
for any reason
you'll get a refund or an exchange no
questions asked
no caveats give me that used underwear
let me sniff it once and then i'll
incinerate it
okay so to get 50 off your first order
and free shipping go to meundies.com
that's communities.com thank you please
support our sponsor if you love this
show thank you so much
when it comes to paying off debt it can
often feel like an uphill battle
high interest rates resulting in a
minimum monthly payment keeps you an
endless cycle of debt upstart is the
fast and easy way to pay off your debt
with a personal loan all
online all in one consolidation we live
for that
thanks upstart upstart is the fast and
easy way to pay off your debt with a
personal loan online
whether it's paying off credit card debt
consolidating high interest debt
or funding personal expenses over half a
million people have already used upstart
to get a simple fixed monthly payment
unlike other lenders upstart looks at
more than just your credit score
like your income employment history and
how attractive you are
i'm just kidding i added that oh great
joke and send us a photo and we'll rate
how attractive you are
and your loan will be cheaper well
that's how the world works doesn't it
no not with upstart not without start
not as fast as one business day after
accepting your loan that's pretty quick
that's like the quickest one i've had
with five minute online rate check you
could see your rate up front oh did uh
with a five minute online rate check you
could see your rate up front for loans
between 1000 and fifty thousand dollars
yeah and you get it super fast so here's
a call to action
find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payment today by going to
upstart.com
that's upstart.com don't forget to use
our url to let them know
we sent you loan amount will be termed
oh this is the one we read really fast
loan amount will determine based on your
credit income and certain
other information provided in your loan
application go to upstart.com you
somebody has stopped me
that was really good cringe you look
like him you should do a photo like that
for your instagram tomorrow
my camera do you side by side can i show
you that oh yeah send that to dan too so
people can see there it is oh
that's awesome yeah pretty good right
yeah it's really good i pushed my armor
a little just for transparency
yeah i got a little bit like the fatness
on them but yeah okay just for chin to
fancy because we don't want to be like
chloe either we don't want to send out a
damaging message
let everybody know the arm is can you
have the before arm i want to see that
before
actually i don't think i do because um
my makeup artist took the photo you
incinerated it
yeah i can't i can't get this phone send
it i can find i can get her descended
okay
you want to talk about the wrestling
everyone got mad at you for the
wrestling today wait what wrestling
the last episode i said i didn't want to
wrestle you in that yeah i did a
rebuttal video
well i saw you putting up all these tick
tocks and videos and i was like wait
what's happening
why is tricia talking about the
wrestling thing so we back comments as
if i'm like
no like i'm trying to push you to touch
me i was like oh my god that's
literally not no i think people were
just upset
because you because i said i wasn't
comfortable and then you
kept pushing and so
dude your thumbnail game's crazy i don't
pick them they just generate them yo by
the way this i want to show this
this was another recent one of your
thumbnails epic
oh my god what is this good
so good you had another thumbnail like
this when you're like james charles is a
dangerous predator and it looked like
this it's like a monster face
if you're thinking of plastic surgery
don't really yeah
especially with the face like that
i wouldn't recommend it either messed up
no my sister just got lipo on her chin
and stomach and
did i feel so bad she was so beautiful i
mean she she's gonna look bomb and it
does look good like i've had spot
surgery it looked good
but i just she's like in pain and i'm
just like oh i just i cried because i
was just like oh my god why did you do
it you're so beautiful
not that it's not gonna look bad i'm
just like the fact that she's in pain
for a couple weeks it like makes me so
sad
should i just be fat and get eat pizza
and burgers you know what i think you
should just eat when you're hungry and
if you decide to eat healthy if you
don't what if i'm always hungry
eat whatever you feel it's called
intuitive eating intuitive eating and do
it my encompass is way the [ __ ] off
clearly
don't tell me to intuitively i think
you're really good at like moderate i do
think you're good at like balancing
stuff i think you're i think you should
just eat how you want and like
you know sometimes i you feel it in your
body if i eat too much fat food like i
haven't stopped eating you know what i
mean i don't know i feel like i've been
so much happier just eating what
saying i'm happy for you you're happy
are you happy are you yeah
listen i'm happy with my life and
everything i just i
i talk about this all the time so i'm so
over it because i just talk about i feel
like people are just annoyed with me
complaining about this all the time yeah
i don't want to be fat but i love eating
do you understand
jack black watch school of rock it'll
change your whole mind it will
yeah it'll reset your brain look how
angry you are
oh yeah anyway so people were angry
because i said i didn't want to wrestle
you
okay but i missed the whole point no i
understood eventually you were like
you're like i was on the wrestling team
and you had some trauma from that and i
was like okay
because guys would be like i don't wanna
touch your boobs and then one guy was
like oh it's a girl like it's just it's
so
deep-rooted and no it's beyond that if
and these are people all the comments
are people who have never been
sexualized
like being sexualized for your boobs at
a young age just because you're a girl
people don't want to touch you so i was
trying to figure out what i was asking
and i really was trying to figure out
is like is it a sexual thing where
you're like oh it's like a little too
sexual i don't want to do that
or is it like strictly because you
thought my body was gross or was it
because i'm
like i was trying to figure it out i
don't know what to tell you i'm not here
to i'm not
i'm not in a hip hypnotic state i'm not
doing psychotherapy i just know that i
don't want to wrestle you
no but for me for my own thing because
it was such a good trigger i get it i
get it i know when i was a girl
it was cold because i had boobs but then
like no it was because you were a girl
i'm like was it because i have boobs or
is it because i'm a girl like i don't
know what the
what it is and it's like that can be
like so frustrating because people just
sexualize you because you have boobs
and like even today like just anything
well not just you but like anyone like
is
scared to touch me like my dad didn't
want to hug me because my stepmom's like
she has boobs that's inappropriate and i
was like
why like it's so but you had to agree to
that too you're like it's weird to hug
females like that's why i was wondering
what i didn't say that yeah weird to hug
females when you're talking about
analyzing hugs you said you like a side
hug because it is like you don't want to
touch someone's chest well i'm not gonna
yeah
i mean yeah because i i i'm not gonna
give you like a big embrace
no because it's all tit i get it i'm not
saying that
i mean you got the big ass titties here
no i know what this happened think about
like being a girl at like nine years old
you have big boobs and your dad won't
hug you because your stepmom's like
that's inappropriate
i mean that's that's that's your family
being [ __ ] no it's different it's
totally different like with you and
whoever you don't want to hug me don't
hug me i'm not i'm not a huggy person
anyways but it's just like
oh it's just like frustrating that's why
it's coming from and then everyone was
like saying don't pressure ethan
i'm like i don't want you no i people i
get it you
you got there was a trigger there i
didn't understand i understood by the
end
and i think people it's fine they said
bobby lee would wrestle me though so
maybe i'll
well here this is what i was going to
say is um we can wrestle on that
i don't need us we can get the sumo
suits that's literally my body now you
didn't want to touch it so now you want
to touch it like
looking just wait you don't want to do
this what's the difference
the difference is i don't have to touch
you okay but that no but you are that's
what i'm trying to see the difference
because that's still
wrestling a girl i i don't have a
problem wrestling a girl i just don't
want to touch your body
too much physical contact but that is
physical contact yeah but i'm not
touching you it's a giant sumo suit
you're literally touching me there's
like gro there's grasping there's like
it's it's a hug it's different i don't
have to tell you
it's so you don't want to do this with
me
i mean i'll no because now you make it
so weird
we don't know let's drop the wrestling
we don't have to rest nobody's wrestling
joe rogan i'll wrestle you too
and and i could take reuters people all
day long allegedly if he's on words i
don't know but like i've
i've wrestled the road boyfriend
technically he was an abusive boyfriend
but i
beat the [ __ ] out of him too he would
just punch me and i'd punch him so but
this was a defense thing don't come for
me because now people are getting a
sexual assault but he like he hit my
face anyways is that too graphic maybe i
shouldn't say all this
i'm
someone famous who is it i can't say he
hit you first
yeah i shouldn't say this i didn't [ __ ]
him up no i pushed him off is what i
should say
now that sounds bad maybe this is a bad
conversation but he came for me first
okay what's his name where is he though
no he's scary for real and like
i think yeah i keep getting sued people
keep threatening [ __ ] him up just tell
me his name where he lives i'll get him
wait are you not a fighter no i'll get
my ass kicked by anyone okay
literally anyway me too i take it back
joe where are you probably that's why
it's so funny like when this guy sam
tripoli
just in our last episode we recorded he
wanted to fight me because i said i'm
pro-vaccine passport
i was like bro what makes you think i
want to fight you you dumb [ __ ] piece
of [ __ ] like
oh man still got the anger my body well
yeah he he goes
i'll fight you bro because you believe
that people should have vaccine
passports i was like uh bruh
yeah but that's like that i hate to keep
saying about like toxic masculinity
where someone just wants to fight you
like when you got to fight somebody like
masculinity no we are how's that going
to resolve our differences by the way
which are purely intellectual and i just
like wrestling for the sport of it i
don't
want to be anyone up i like just to
wrestle guys and like or girls i'll
wrestle girls too did you know that
pizza is cursed on the show
what every time we get pizza a curse
happens
like listen either we get in a huge
fight when moses came in
we get swatted the last time i got
swatted right
and then the now the the most recent
time we lost all the footage
wow so that's crazy every time we've got
pizza it's been a terrible
tragedy is followed i had the first two
minutes of that last footage on my tic
toc did you see that moses was filming
so i had like the first two minutes oh
yeah of our
eating the lost footage the last it was
sad because it was pretty good and i
don't just say that just to say that i
was a it was kind of a banger at the
beginning of that because i was
chomping that was so full by the time we
uh uh me too bro i love that um i
noticed you you put nfts and you listed
this one
i think i don't get nfts i don't think
my audience gets well i just noticed
because you listed this picture of you
eating spaghetti for 100
ethereum which is equal to about 250
000 oh you think someone will buy it i
was like i was like well
okay i mean hey girl if you see the
value then listed for 100 ethereum
that's worth it yeah it's just a it's a
jpeg of you eating spaghetti it's
totally worth
quarter million bucks has anyone bought
it
no but i have two sold now but not that
price
i don't get it it looks like a hundred
dollars i mean i was like that's worth
100
but you know what maybe it's worth 250
000 to some people did you set it up or
was it moses
you did it i'm kind of impressed that
you even were able to figure it out that
far
well he had the wallet so he transferred
me money into the i can't get the money
out so i have like five thousand dollars
sitting in there and i can't get it down
yeah i think trisha's
two ethereum will be sitting there
forever what if one day that was worth
like two million dollars because i can't
get it out
maybe i'll just leave it i i don't get i
hate out of teeth
i was so you were texting me about it i
was so over it because even that night
well i was following along i was like oh
my god she
so once she listed for a hundred
ethereum and then the other one she
listed
a hundred of the item for one ethereum
which nobody bought weirdly um you were
selling a hundred pictures for one
i think that was still set up wrong
though it was definitely yeah
but no but someone bought one like
within like literally a minute i was
like whoa it's called trish's number one
fan
and then like a couple days later
someone bought one i don't know why you
guys are buying them
they're not they're just literally
thumbnails well you made it so
um you know what it's like fishing
like when i was a hooker you just kind
of fish for people and sometimes you got
a big tuna
that's right maybe someone wants to
spend 25 000 well if anyone's got 100
ethereum laying around you know what to
do with this what if i get 250 000
you should be investigated by the fbi if
i sell no no you'd be good
i don't know how to cash it out though
and you'll you'll figure it out if you
get 100.
i'll help you really yeah you charge me
like 10 percent yeah 10
that's not not much to ask for um it's
so confusing i got over it so quickly i
was like no i'm over it
okay so i've got i've got a few topics
here i've got addison ray
says she's britney spears oh yeah dom
made a comment on the allegations
uh jeff whittick's first part of his
documentary came out
he didn't talk about his accident but he
insinuates what we
knew which is what david it was for
david video and not only that david was
the one operating the excavator
he said that in the part one i mean he
showed images of david on the excavation
oh he did
yeah so i mean he well he called me and
told me to not talk about it so i don't
know
well he she's in the documentary right
also who cares if he asks you not to
talk about it i know but he said he's
like on the
mental version i was just trying not to
but he talked he should
look at his thumbnail he did like the
most click bait thumbnail ever well i
didn't see any of this i what is this
yesterday
i just saw someone tweeted about it yeah
oh can you show that no he did
yeah he showed the video i mean oh he i
think he changed the thumbnail because
it was even worse before it was like
david being like
but anyway yeah oh yeah
the whole thing is horrendous like okay
like watching like the leaked footage
watching that and then like listening to
him like the it's
it's so traumatizing and like this video
kind of funny though because it's like
look how [ __ ] up i am but at the same
time look how bomb i look shirtless
it's like pick one way or the other dude
why you gotta flex on me shirtless
it's like if someone's like a yeah if
you have like you know
you've got go with what you're working
with you know is he a twink
i don't think he's getting he's hairless
and jack no well look i know he's not
gay but i'm just saying like oh
if he was i don't i don't think so he's
too old i think
what's the name for that like just a fit
dude that's just like a
hot game okay top gay top gay
well anyway the truth maybe more of a
bottom gay
oh bottom i think so tall guys are
always the fit guys are
i love bottoms um i feel like all my
friends are bottom say savers but i feel
like
i love a bottom of your bottoms shout
out pink is team bottom over here
are you team top i'm team top yeah cool
i'm gonna talk we gotta talk about is is
demi lovato on there
yes she is okay james charles made up
james charles finally got dropped by
morph
finally and then james put out a
statement threatening to sue people
awesome oh him and apologies
taking accountability does not mean like
also going to sue people it's like i
know
exactly okay so let's talk let's talk
about the stuff actually because i'm
afraid we're gonna run out of time
let's talk about the stuff i'm most
interested in here dirty dom from the
vlog squad he posts an apology which is
again just
about as bad as james is right he says
so gross these guys are all such pieces
of [ __ ] it's like they all want to take
accountability but nobody wants to
[ __ ] fess up
somehow everybody accused of essay it's
a lie
every single time according to the guys
it's a lie it's a fabrication which is
not accountability of the time and you
can't look he takes accountability in
the first paragraph
and then you can't just do the next one
with that being said no that's
it like you just say it you just say
sorry you say let me read this he says
it's time for me just by the way this
comes off him making a tick tock making
fun of the allegations
like yeah yeah okay it is time for me to
address the recent allegations that have
come
out against me i want to seriously
apologize to everyone directed and i
empathize with the pain
that everyone has suffered in the matter
so remember he said he empathizes
with that being said as far as i am
concerned everything
that occurred during the night in
question was completely constitutional
as far as i'm concerned
i don't i i don't know about you know
hey as far as i'm concerned i i didn't
have any trouble
i love that as far as i was concerned
also i feel like people don't understand
that like if you're like
inebriated and you're like you're not
walk out oh here yeah you there's no way
you can give consent like you can't have
sex and someone's like what am i just
not supposed to have sex with a drunk
girl yeah
basically like exactly even like
girlfriend like oh my drunk girlfriend
whatever it's like even that it's like
if someone's drunk just don't
just don't do it like it's just like so
they're not there they're not cohesive
like or they're not i love how he says
as far as i'm concerned that just cracks
me up hey as far as i hey as far as i
care
it was consensual i
ah everything that occurred that night
blah blah blah
i believe the statements that have come
out i guess we are entirely mism
misleading and shed an incorrect light
on my involvement shut up dude we all
[ __ ] see you
so gross like this isn't even like
isolated you're like a known creep bro
just stop
my character is being unfairly attacked
shut up and the statement that exists in
the public eye are unfairly defaming
and assaulting my character and
reputation shut up your reputation is
dirt with reputation
literally even before this your
reputation was dirt you were kicked out
of vlog squad for being a creep bro
yeah with that being said if possible i
want to shed light a positive light on
events nope and have transpired
and show the world who i truly am too
late we already know
i recently donated my time as well
thousands of dollars to several women's
rights group to show my support for the
unjustified and necessary struggles that
women endure in our society on daily
basis bro
stop it it is time for us all to
demonstrate more respect for one another
in every fact of life
facet of life you know it's funny
because he already got exposed once for
groping girl vidcon years ago
yeah and he made a whole video saying oh
i'm gonna change i'm not gonna do this
anymore and here we are again bro
like dude you clearly have not changed
shut the [ __ ] up
just go away photos of a of a pastel
girl
in the parking garage with jeff todd dom
david like there's like there's evidence
that these girls were blacked out like i
don't know why they're still trying to
be like uh they're portraying me in a
different light
no like this is oh it's so gross it's so
gross and i hate that they solve a
platform and like really the only way
is if people press charges just like
that austin kid like you know if someone
presses charge the same thing with james
charles the only way people go to prison
if people are charged some people don't
want to do it
it's a hassle they don't think it's
worth it they don't whatever they but
that's the only way because a lot of
people like why aren't these people in
prison then if they're not because some
people just don't press charges yeah
that's why
because they haven't pressed charges do
you like my hat up like that a little
angle to it
a little bit like dick crazy yeah it's
better for the light oh okay yeah more
green face
are you getting in trouble for green
face against sale boogers
maybe people who's green face
who's green trisha i dare you to say i
don't know i don't know
go ahead what's that what ethnicity is
green i dare you to say
we always say north korea i feel like
that's the safe answer for everything
because when i was watching the moment
wait why i think we don't like north
korea
because they're korean they're just
people i'm saying because nobody likes
north korea because it's communist i
thought that was ours yeah but the
ethnicity is the same
people are really
we don't hate north koreans we hate kim
jong-un no but when i said adapting from
a country
where nobody wants babies you can't
adopt from north korea because the
government is [ __ ]
but i thought that was our safe so i
apologize north korea they're not green
they're people
i meant because that was the safe
country to come for
i can't believe you said they're green
stop i didn't mean like i'm kidding
nobody's nobody calls me god so anyway
any thoughts on turkey he will
i get so much he yo what's with his name
dirty what is that is he trying to say
dirty
what is his name i've been wondering is
it dominick
so what is the dirt why does he spell it
like that trying to be
clever epic oh for real i thought it was
his last name or something
no anyway he's a creep he's the worst
and
duerte is a name duarte dirty duerte
it's a last name that many people have
maybe that's his last name i don't know
he's
i wanna he's also daca i believe
really oh yeah that's trouble
well i'll tell you what david's gonna be
in trouble after this jeff
documentary is he though i feel like he
gets away with just everything
especially because once again jeff will
be
the one have pressed charges and he's
not going to like and it's fine again
well i actually talked
i talked this over with dan the problem
is jeff doesn't need
i'm gonna we'll talk about this but
the problem is is that he needed a
special license
and supervision to operate that
excavator
and that i don't think jeff needs to
press charges against him for
who ha but someone has to well if not
necessarily it's a crime against the
state
yeah if there's a state right it's a
crime against this state
i doubt that will happen but we don't
have all the info maybe he did go out of
his way to get licensed maybe that's
a totally new point but to operate a
heavy machinery like that
we just don't know when i saw i just saw
that again through like a different
means i didn't look at just documentary
but when i saw that he was right that
like
my stomach dropped i texted you and my
stomach like dropped because it was like
this whole other level of like
[ __ ] like i felt bad i kind of not not
felt bad for david because like it was
his
dumb ass but like it almost made me feel
bad because now this is like someone's
life that he ruined like he like oh yeah
he gave jeff life-changing injuries
brain damage blindness and like that's a
lot of guilt and i'm sure i know david's
not like
he's always saying this was in his
documentary he showed david in the
excavator in his documentary so yeah i'm
not
ah i'm not stepping out of turn here um
because i know the guilt he's gonna live
with so i feel bad for him i mean at the
same time he's a dumb ass
but i know like when you when you do
that to someone you gave someone
blindness you gave someone like brain
damage like all the stuff jeff has said
like
it's i i don't know how you even and
from what jeff said on impulsive not to
bring that up because i know he said
i knew you were going to bring up
impulsive i jokingly said to trisha
before the podcast starts you got
anything about impulsive you want to
bring up today
i didn't until oh my god like my source
of how i know that
jazz said he hadn't talked to when that
episode was filmed which they kept
saying impulsive this was still march
12th because it was clearly he said we
hadn't talked to david
in like six months or seven months dude
that's that's their mo they cut people
out when something goes sideways
yeah i guess he said they like somebody
tried to film like a mukbang with him
after but he was like not about it and
so i guess he's just kinda
okay so um he's not anti-dave because i
talked to him on the phone because
whatever but he's not anti-david and
i'm really not either but this is such a
scene like i told him i'm like if you
have
this blind like you have to have some
sort of somewhere compensation somewhere
because your life is ruined and changed
and like all this stuff life-changing
injury not right
it's a life-changing injury so so what
happened was that they went out to this
lake to film this video
for david's vlogs and there's this thing
where you get an excavator
and you like wakeboard and you hold on
to the claw well date so
when i say i don't know if it's for
david's vlog if it's a sponsorship or if
it's just video there's like speculation
for all three of those things so we
don't know but david was well
and okay i mean well just to say it's
not for david's vlog i don't know for
sure okay
thank you for the correction so um
so what happened was uh i saw the video
actually
not like the close-up because i heard
there's a close-up video that's really
gory and like
scary because they thought he was gonna
die yeah but i saw
there was people on the beach filming it
so i saw it from far away but what
happened is he's spinning around
david starts spinning him around really
fast and then suddenly stops it and he
slams into the
the arm of the of the excavator
and then falls into the water and the
thing is
no helmet by the way no help yeah
exactly
so when i first heard of how his injury
actually happened which was
this kind like david uh doing this
excavator gag for a video
i was like man who the big question for
my mind is who was driving it because
one you need a special license to
operate an excavator that is a dangerous
machine
and you need to be properly trained to
operate that that is not a joke
you can get seriously injured and you
can't just [ __ ] around on
a machine like that i mean this is
serious this is a serious machine it's
extremely dangerous
and so when i found out that it was
actually david driving
um that put everything over the line for
me where i was like
this is so he is so irresponsible yeah
he
he is not safe to be around he is so
brutally irresponsible
to put his friends and even himself in
that position
um i was blown away he's talked about on
the podcast that like if if
like he accidentally killed like he said
you always joke about like accidentally
like killing one of his friends
i feel like one day that's gonna happen
it's like well you almost did yeah and
it's just
it's so like my stomach like you feel so
sick over this because and again like
he's at fault for this like this if he
would have like died he would have been
charged for a manslaughter you know like
oh for sure he would have been charged
but i think he is respon if it was for a
video for him
he has a responsibility to ensure
everybody's safety and to make sure that
there's someone who knows how to operate
that machine and that there's a medic
there and all this stuff and that the
people have helmets on and stuff
but the fact that he didn't have any of
that and that it was him
operating the vehicle makes me really
like wow just shocks me that he did this
life-changing
injury to jeff and then he ghosted him
according to what you said
according to what just said on impulsive
according to what jeff said on
david he said he doesn't talk to so it
could be i mean what the [ __ ]
maybe i didn't talk to him after that i
don't know so i won't say david just
didn't reach out to him maybe jeff
decided not to yeah i mean that's that's
that's psychotic the guy i would think
that david would feel totally
responsible
to pay for his medical bills and
probably even give him a settlement
because he's [ __ ] his whole life i
don't know for sure but i think he's
paying for his build but
nothing more than that is what i get so
if he's paying for his bills then i do
think that means that
there's it was for him i mean he also
was the one driving he caused the
accident
exactly he caused it yeah he david
[ __ ] why is my
leg drooping a settlement especially
because that
because jeff just hasn't been able he
tried to work and he just he can't like
he just
oh oh bro i need some do we have a
sponsor i know i need some blue
is that blue is that what it's called
yeah we're saying that generic uh
viagra really it's called blue okay um
i i feel yeah the situation it's just
it's horrid
it's absolutely [ __ ] horrid and by
the way in retrospect how there was like
this big hush hush nobody talk about it
nobody knows what happened
and david and all of his friends were
there and they all knew what happened
and
everybody's just like hush hush hush
protect david
now after watching the first part of
jeff's documentary
yeah i did get this insight into what
kind of guy he is and
like he has like a criminal history and
he's comes from a hard neighborhood
the whole no but he was doing he got
arrested he had like a ton of cocaine
and ecstasy and we just stuff he
he was not a violent criminal no he's
not a violent yeah he was
he was a big time he was a big time
dealer yeah
he was supposed to do 15 years in jail
but they didn't have a search warrant so
it got thrown out
but anyway i understand from his
background that he like he's kind of
just like
i'm gonna handle my own [ __ ] i'm not
gonna snitch on my friend
all this kind of like whatever stuff
like i get that
but at the same time david the fact that
he just went on like nothing
is beyond [ __ ] insane oh the amount
of
guilt i would feel i mean i'm guilty
about everything now and i just like say
everything i like say as much as i can
because that's so that's crazy
and to go about like you said like
normal like everybody he's like people
wanted to film mukbangs with me after
like
the like and just film stupid bits he's
like i don't want to do that [ __ ] and
it's like yeah
he was seriously injured i think he
almost died
because like in the video you can see
his skull was cracked like his whole
skull was cracked
all the way down his forehead his eye
came out apparently they had to sew his
eyelid on it looked really
um really bad and also from like what
like our conversation like i mean he
just
like i just don't think he talks like
really anything he says he has real
friends now because i said i'm like
i asked him because i generally was like
concerned like are you going to like a
therapist because he said he has like a
lot of mental like
issues he's struggling with and stuff
and um he said he hasn't he's going to
start i'm like
he has not he said yeah and oh god maybe
we should have him back on after his
documentary's done
to do a little wrap-up interview would
that be nice do we like that
i mean i like jab and i've always like
i've always said good things about him
because of everyone in the group i feel
like he's good but and then he
removed the video that's what i said he
goes i look like an idiot on your show
because i talked to him on thursday and
it's like
honestly you even just like coming on
and talking is one really brave too you
like acknowledge and apologize the
second time to like everybody and took
down the video like cat and stuff like
that
i said i have no issue with you because
even this he's like oh i don't want to
talk about this in a bad way and i was
like first of all know what because he's
scared people are gonna look at him as a
dumbass and i was like
why he i saw the video he didn't do
anything david was spinning it
it was all david's fault from what i
could tell but but jeff has so much
embarrassment from it that he like
didn't want people to know like he's
like shameful he's like i don't know
because his a friend of his and i think
his dad were like you're a dumb ass why
did you do that so i think he had this
thing where everyone's gonna call him a
dumbass like if anything people have
like a lot of
empathy for you because i don't think so
i don't think it's embarrassing for him
i think he was there
trying to make content for his friend
and his friend i don't think
david didn't do it on purpose but he
doesn't know how to operate this machine
that's the problem
he doesn't have the license i think he
might have it but i
[ __ ] doubt it i'm just saying that to
cover my ass here but like come on
and um and he and he neglected he
negligently injured his friend and this
isn't the first time so like there was a
guy that joe and i told you he had a
step where he was supposed to do like a
motorbike over a pool
and he missed it and he like he had
something with his head he had a head
injury this was like i don't know three
years ago
and i said in a video like it's [ __ ]
insane because he's big enough
you you have this team apparently you
know what i mean like
have someone with a [ __ ] brain around
who knows
and not one of them could get like a
medic or someone to like supervise the
stunts or someone with a [ __ ] license
stunt coordinator jackass had all of
those people when you look at the
credits they had like all of the people
well that's the difference between
jackass and david's vlogs
is that you have people behind jackass
people that are actually responsible
adults people have been seriously
injured vlogs before like he's
this has happened so much it's not like
he wants like oops like you know
i think this just solidifies what we've
been saying is that he is a
deeply irresponsible person that
endangers the people around him to make
content
and this isn't just this is now you have
someone who was essayed
you have someone who with life changing
injuries
and each time there was an uh a um
attempt to
cover up and move on and to cut from
your
life dom cut obviously that makes sense
but the fact that he just dropped jeff
to me
is soul-wrenchingly [ __ ] horrible dom
wasn't also dropped we had said
there was a video of 2020 right before
the epidemic wasn't really doing like a
merch blog not only that but like they
went to dom's party remember that party
he was going to go on tour
right in 2020 oh my god right so they
were all there supporting him in 2020
in like february so i saw a lot of
people by the way saying
that david didn't know about um i saw
this on tick tock because apparently
they don't watch frenemies [ __ ]
losers
but people keep saying we like some of
you oh i love the people that love us on
tick tock come on bro you know
you know one love but people were saying
that they didn't
know david didn't know what dom did and
that's actually
provably false because david removed the
video
after dom got the text which means that
dom showed david the text or at least
explained why he needed to remove that
video
proving david knew about it yeah no
david did
and he left the comment about like good
job coming clean like the first time it
happened like the second time he knew
like he just knew good job buddy
oh yeah when did when he was like yeah i
grew up to girl vidcon he's like hey
he's what's his classic line he says
being a being an idiot
is easy but taking credibility is hard
good job buddy
this is just crazy no one talked about
it either it's like that's like everyone
just stay quiet about this
it's like it's so crazy oh you know what
was even crazier because you mentioned
on the show that the accident happened
like this
and then on the david dobrik subway
because they did such an
unprecedented job of scrubbing this in
this video off the internet somehow
that people were like this video doesn't
exist and trisha is lying people were
accusing you of lying and making up
all over the david dover block uh
subreddit yeah when the uh
trailer for it came out the trailer for
jeff's documentary
uh i went and checked out like how it
was being received in
david's community or whatever and they
all took the trailer
the scene of the parachuting they're
like oh he injured himself parachuting
so that story about excavator trisha
made the whole thing up that was like
what everybody was saying and then the
next day it comes down it's like oh no
wait it wasn't well don't
don't feel bad because after his trailer
cut everyone now was like oh
trish was right again trisha's right
again i'm just so used to people
thinking i lied
like whatever it comes out or it comes
out you know it doesn't but but like how
like the fact that they
underwent this like how do you erase a
video off the internet like that this
doesn't happen there's people on the
server being like i can't find the
internet
the footage just doesn't exist like how
do you do that i mean that they were
making this
unbelievable effort to scrub the
internet of this video
to just [ __ ] brush over the fact that
you gave your friend life injuring
life-changing injuries from what jeff
told me is he's gonna put it out
and he it'll be demonetized by like
youtube but he's gonna he has the
footage and he wants to be able to
release it because his mom hasn't seen
it yet
he says it's his footage to really yeah
and so he i think he has all the
i think he said he's going to he's like
i'm not like trying to hide or anything
like you know
he's he said he's not trying to like
cover he said he was trying to make it
like a documentary and make it like you
know keep people guessing and
the first part came out so quickly after
our conversation i talked to him
thursday and this came out like sunday i
guess so yeah i watched
he was trying i'm gonna watch it all you
know i always told him i have support i
said the only reason i ever came for you
was you came for me and said
trisha has like mental illness she's you
know like she's a liar she wasn't there
so that's why like i had an issue with
him i have no
issue other than that because i think he
thinks i wasn't trying to come for him
and i'm like literally never
well there was the starbucks incident
we still talked about that on the phone
he's like it's so funny
so that's the jeff documentary that that
oh there's another thing just
jason apparently was cheating on you i
don't know if you care about this
but according to this tick tock version
my mom had broken up with jason by then
she was with huey
and then huey lewis um but they were
still kind of friends they would text
sometimes
and this is all from my mom obviously
i'm not like in her fall look at this
but this is what she's told me
um and she told me that whenever she was
texting jason or like they wanted to
hang out just as bugs
um he would sometimes be like hey like
don't text me right now i'm with trisha
she
like will get so jealous don't text me
like she'll find out and stuff and it
was really
really weird like i don't know that's
it was like she wasn't allowed to text
him because like trisha would get super
duper my mom didn't care at all she was
like okay
whatever like i don't really enjoy
hanging out with you that much and
anyways you know like it was like this
is a big deal but she was like
whenever she texted him they had to be
wary about
if like trish was gonna see and so he
definitely
uh it got weird right there and i think
that's when my mom was finally like okay
i'm just not gonna
so what are your thoughts apparently
jason was cheating on you
mom her mom did a tick tock her mom's
like in her 40s which is fine it's like
not a shaming but like
her mom does tic tacs being like jason
just loved being famous and he was a
pervert in his own adult way
it's like now we weren't just coming
forward just to say jason's a perfect
which he is but it's like if he's an
adult and you're adult people it's fine
but it's more like we should focus on
him being like creepy and hang out with
like
young teenage kids and stuff like that
anyways but he doesn't bother that he
cheated on you he didn't
that like that's where he has so many
inconsistencies one if he did because it
earlier
this is gonna be something like a crazy
ex-girlfriend but i was on his phone all
the time i went through all his text
messages and
like all the time he'd literally just
hand me his phone like he literally had
his passcode and everything
and we were with him every day never
cheated on me i can guarantee he'd never
cheat on me everything else he's like a
creep afterwards yeah he's disgusting
and he's like
manipulative probably early on like she
said her mom dated him in 2017 and we
weren't dating we were like cooking up
so she's
talking about 2017 it's and but again i
don't care when people like tweet me and
it's fine i'll talk about it because i
love you know i'll talk about
gossip all day long but also it's like
i'm like engaged now so when people are
like oh my gosh you're just gonna make a
video about this like i'm not like i'll
talk about in front of me for those
clicks you know what i'm saying but like
i don't
care there was one about a young girl
like
some young girl that's dating him like
what does church have to say i don't
care i mean he's creepy and manipulative
and he's but we know this like let's
let's focus on him being like a creep
and like all and the set thing let's
just focus on all the bad stuff that he
has done like him like
dating people in 2017 like okay is it
not weird this girl just like airing out
her mom's dirty laundry
very weird what was that and she was
like interviewing her mom for the tick
tock and her mom has like wine shows
jason loves being famous and he'll take
advantage of that it's like okay i don't
know
now everyone has stories about jason
which again it's his own fault he's just
an idiot and he just like you know
whatever but
it's like a lot and then it distracts
from like the serious stuff like the
seth stuff so now people are just like
oh jason [ __ ] a 22 year old like
okay like that it is gross and
disgusting you're like a creep but
okay so jason was faithful not a cheater
i was with him every day since we
actually officially started because i'm
clingy i won't like leave a [ __ ]
site you know i know you guys got in a
fight over
over not being able to access his phone
yeah i access his phone but also now
like and once you do access someone's
phone
you like don't care i literally don't
care about most i have his instagram i
don't ever check it
that's good i mean i you have to give
that up
at some point the possessiveness i think
it was just like i had a lot of trauma
from like
previous boyfriends but i like jason was
the first person i didn't see on me and
like
again i know even on tour people would
like video him and he'd be like i don't
i can't like give you a hug like your
show will be like a mad
i think maybe that's maybe what she was
saying because he would say he goes i
don't want to like hug you oh he's like
don't text me because i don't want to
yeah i mean that's okay so maybe that
but i know for a fact like i
checked his dms and phones all the time
and he like and he was i mean
and even in his oh i won't go to that
but even in his marriage like he didn't
have sex for like a long time and he
didn't cheat on her and i believe that
there you go
not a cheater just a creep super creepy
yeah you're also like 48 thought you had
hip surgery that's when you're too old
to [ __ ] 22 year olds like stop it
maybe that'll because like i saw a 22
year old do a video about him and she
was really upset and you could tell
she's just very like young and he's just
like a creep he just stopped talking to
her and he goes to her and i'm like
that's what happens
it's just like oh god oh man i'm
manipulative like
i i was watching me clefa talk about
this and she's like if an older guy says
like you're mature for your age
they're not you're not oh yeah that's
dude oh yeah yeah she's 18 but she's so
mature for it
really dude no it's so i love that and
it's very rare like 22 years nobody's
mature for their age everybody's their
age
22 year olds don't just want to hook up
with you and so when he's surprised that
she called the hollywood fix on him and
something i'm like
because they want she wants them to know
that she's [ __ ] like she's hanging
out with you or [ __ ] or whatever i
would like that at 23.
i wouldn't expose everyone as [ __ ] i
was like oh i'm [ __ ] christman glover
you know what i mean like you just
no one knows christmas glover anymore
but [ __ ] would you call that cloud
[ __ ]
i think just like as a young girl you
want fame you want notoriety you know
and it's cool like you're
she obviously hat was a fan of him and
so she's super uncomfortable
um you should get measurements by him
but he'll come to your house it's just
the paint in the back is rubbing with
the jacket
oh it's getting uncomfy it's a lot you
look good maybe some
ac moses could you kick the ac down a
little bit thank you maybe um
oh there's something god
i don't put you in that bubble if you do
believe god you believe in something
higher being i don't i'm agnostic i
really have no opinion about
any of that stuff it's like the first
thing you don't have an opinion on
yeah love that that's good i have no i
really have no
strong opinion about uh if there's a god
or not
that's good because could you imagine
you're doing politics and religion then
you just have everyone hate you and then
your podcast will cease to exist
yeah well that's i mean that's what the
right-wingers do they do
but that's what they love they're people
they love god they love jesus and they
love
uh and they hate immigrants i don't know
what's their platform after the show
love jesus hate immigrants
yeah i love immigrants hamilton
immigrants we get the job done yeah
immigrants are great they've always been
great for this country my fiance is an
immigrant
it's absolutely [ __ ] absurd that how
immigrants are um
we don't get political but how they're
like demonized in this country it's a
[ __ ] joke
immigrants have and will always be uh
a positive net positive for this country
artists working
they work so hard they contribute a lot
you know it's it's ridiculous i am proud
to be engaged with an immigrant
green card baby he has a green card i
hate that joke he has one
well now that i've been here 25 years
i'm only now confident ila's not with me
for the green card now that we've been
married for like eight years
i was like okay once theodore was born i
was like okay she's probably not going
to leave me
but even if someone is with someone for
a green card like at least they get
companionship for a couple years
right yeah it's a good trade-off those
guys know they're like listen i'm gonna
get to
i'm gonna get to be spend time with you
for a few years and you're gonna leave
me i get that but sometimes they don't
have sex with the people and then they
get pissed like ninety fiance remember
danielle muhammad
muhammad and danielle she peed on him
during sex once and never again he had
sex with her and she goes he would not
have sex with me and she
who peed on who muhammad and danielle
you don't remember that they want to
feed on her
danielle peed on mohammed one time
during sex we never had sex with her
again and she at the reunion she was
here
why did she pee on him for a kink or for
an accident i think maybe an accident
she's like an older woman
and he would stay in front of her
teenage kids she'd be like i want my
sex or you're getting deported that's
awesome
oh yeah you better pay up dude you know
why you're there that's how we role play
i want my sex week i'm just kidding no
he has he's
honestly 90 day fiance is such a crazy
show man this season was wild
and you know yeah it's usually the guys
bringing over like hot young
ukrainian girls but there was actually a
lot of older ladies recently
um and the older ladies that look for
like the young
trophy husbands or the weirdest ones by
far who's the one that went down like to
like jamaica or something
yeah and so there's this one girl who's
like middle-aged white lady
so she's like in love with this um
jamaican guy
i don't know if you're making something
but like she's so sex obsessed she's
like i want sex three times tonight
i was like holy [ __ ] or when they're
tired they come in and like they're
tired like the
the woman that lives in the apartment
with the guy from like i don't know one
of those places she goes
oh i want to have sex and he's just like
i'm tired and she gets so pissed
no [ __ ] you know what this is but the
craziest part is
so she went to jamaica to visit him yeah
and they had a big blowout
and so then she started sleeping with
his cousin
is it this uh couple yeah yeah yeah yeah
and then she's
that exactly that's her name and then
she started [ __ ] that's
stephanie and uh ryan
so you show the picture of his cousin
because she as soon as they broke up she
started [ __ ] his cousin and then
talked
about i want you to move to america she
[ __ ] his cousin before too
yeah i know that they're from uh belize
yeah that's where it was
but like the next day she's working on
the paperwork
to bring his cousin over like she just
wants some she just wants
saying sometimes it's just companionship
and no she wants this
outsourced belief's dick no that you
remember stacy and darcy they had their
own show and they would always date four
men that was like their habit they kept
like applying for the k-1 visa with new
guys
and sometimes you know that's about
control you know what it is too a lot of
older women over here are not like you
know they don't get they want young men
that american guys aren't going to go
for the older women so they go for the
foreign men that need that green card
honestly i was on that route i'd be like
moroccan
you know if it wasn't you know maybe
wait you were going to go to you wanted
to be a
male or bride or get a mail order bread
i don't want to be one i don't want to
go somewhere why you're doing so good
what do you need to be a male or brother
no i don't i don't want to be one i want
to get one
you want to get one when
no when we had a break i remember
telling him i'm like i'm gonna go to
israel and find someone that just looks
like you and bring them over
oh you could definitely do that yeah you
can import in israeli so if i wanted to
make him jealous like if he ever like
broke up with me i'd be like i'm gonna
go israel and find someone just
like it's pretty insane but yeah you
could do that for sure yeah they would
they would
i true story i knew somebody that
was in a relationship with an israeli
guy she was a girl
because he had paid her like 20 thousand
dollars
to marry uh him and get a green card
yeah
so there's there's people that will
literally pay you for free
israelis are the shadiest [ __ ]
in this planet
and i say that with peace and love
because i lived there for five years
who comes here it does it shady as [ __ ]
bro like i met so many israel
they all i don't know how they do it
because we mean eva had such a hard time
getting over here
and doing it legitly and there's all
these israelis are like yeah no i got in
my green card because my uncle
has a fence business and he and then i
married my [ __ ]
some lady and i said blah blah blah and
i was like holy [ __ ] these guys are
doing like somersaults to get this [ __ ]
no they are shady i had a locksmith that
like literally would call oh no
no my locks would always break every
month like every month you'll come fix
it
and you charge me like 350 dollars dude
israelis are
don't ever hire israelis for for manual
labor i swear to god
you're the worst and i'm saying that
with peace and love because they come
over here
the israelis they hustle in israel they
know what it is to hustle and live like
a hard life
so they come here and they see all the
because americans are like trusting
and they come over here and it's just
like [ __ ] green pastures for them bro
israeli guys are a lot more respectful i
talked to jenna jameson do you know who
that is
uh uh
no comment so flex over here i used to
be neighbors for john jameson so i know
her and so we talk
whatever her husband is israeli they've
been married like eight years they have
a daughter together and all stuff like
that and so when i got with
moses oh i'm so happy that like you're
with an israeli they like
you know love and treat women and it's
true like i've never been like in a
better relationship but i don't know if
it's because he's really
i don't think it's a generalization i
think it's just true of all people
everywhere some are good some are better
no but they both
we both did porn jenna jamison and now
she hasn't so maybe israeli people are
open to dating porn stars there's a
whole diversity of people from israel
no well well i can but i won't get
stoned if i go to israel
just because i did porn no where were
you going to get stoned i mean
jordan he told me jordan i'd get stoned
if i go there yeah yeah
yeah don't go to jordan do you remember
uh ozen and brittany or yazan and
brittany and she and she was just taking
sexy instagram photos he's like my
family will kill me
yeah and they're like we won't murder
him and then he's like i love her
no jor yeah i wouldn't recommend going
to most middle eastern countries
i wouldn't go there no jordan uh
i wouldn't go to any middle eastern
country like
just because i don't wa as a jew and as
a dual israeli citizen first of all i'm
not even allowed
yeah you're not but in general i just i
don't okay flex
double citizen love that i want to do
that so exciting
yeah i mean well you have to well
yeah it was easy for me because they
just hand it out if you're jewish it's
pretty crazy really
yeah damn oh we i might convert to
judaism
um he knows a rabbi that will help me
convert
are you guys going to do like the fast
lane conversion is he going to do like a
like a vip conversion
really you just pay him a bunch of money
gives you a repeat conversion no she has
to read the book yeah
you know show intention they want to see
can you do aliyah if you convert
after that yeah so you can be a citizen
i'm on the i'm on the route will you
just die if i become a real jewish
will you die if i become real jewish
like a real jewish woman
my kids will be jewish i don't care go
convert what the [ __ ] do i like so no
people can no longer say that i'm
being inappropriate if i am an actual
jewish you seen the seinfeld
you seen the seinfeld episode where his
dentist converts to judaism and the next
day he's making all these jew jokes
that's what you remind me of a little
bit i say it out of the way he goes hey
he converts and one day later he's like
hey come on you know us jews you know
how it is
and he's like should you be making that
joke too so soon one day we'll be able
to say us jews
rightfully and religiously and
righteously you convert
i will i will include you and the
proverbial i'm doing it we're doing it
okay yeah let that not be the only
reason you want to convert them
it's not me fiance it should be because
you love yahweh
our kids will be jewish i want i want
them to go to hebrew school i want them
to do all of that i think that's amazing
i want
james charles huge news on the james
charles front
is he in jail justice is coming for
james not in the
sense of going to prison but not yet
okay so here's one really
what was that sorry i didn't know he was
there i wanted to go extend my feet did
you pick shredder again
let's see the bingo card for frenemies
mentioning impulsive kicking my dog
it looks like my shoes i thought these
were my shoes i was trying to slip my
foot look at that i was trying to slip
my foot into it
yeah it looks just like him i know oops
so james charles has been completely
demonetized by youtube
there's no ads on confirmed i confirmed
because we went well it was reported and
then we went to his channel we were
clicking around and there's no ads on
any of his videos i mean try to check
that dance
see if you get it the rumors but i don't
know if like we
checked it and there was no ads although
weirdly there's been no statement from
youtube or james but i do know that
they've
they do this when people get into into
[ __ ] and i don't think there's any
better reason to do monetize someone's
channel
james is like the worst of the worst out
there right now for sure
so not only did youtube uh apparently
demonetize his old channel his entire
channel
um but more finally put out his morphe
morphe [ __ ] you morphy you're morphed to
me i'm clicking around on various videos
of his
uh nothing no no ads so oh wow
apparently didn't he
uh he monetized his apology video people
were saying really oh i'm not sure but i
purposely didn't click that one because
i figured he didn't but
i'm just i'm just opening random videos
on his channel i mean that's
that i'm not getting it i wonder if it's
a temporary suspension or a permanent
one
yeah don't know it's probably temporary
they always get their
their stuff how do you even just like
yes you did um
reach out to like 17 young boys 10 of
them miners
but you could get monetization back in
two weeks it's like i'm sorry what well
i don't know
i don't know either like that is you
should be d platformed on tick tock too
like all those places
just get rid of him on those social
medias like they did you know
well morphy finally put out a statement
they said in light of the recent
allegations against james charles
morphy and james have agreed to end why
agreed what do you need his permission
for [ __ ] face why are you trying to save
face for jamie i don't know yeah
we together have mutually agreed and and
respect and admiration for each other
wait they say that no no no i'm reading
between the lines yeah i was like what
james charles who has made us millions
of dollars with great admiration and
appreciation for all he's done for us
have agreed to end our business
relationship and wind down sales for the
morphe
x james charles product they're winding
it down
it has and it's always been murphy's
goal to create a positive safe and
empowering
environment where all beauty lovers can
freely share their artist
artistry and passion for cosmetics and
morphe is committed to furthering that
goal
as well as to continuing to set up young
boys for james charles to knock down
like ben like pins they say in light of
recent allegations james admitted
his xt miners just say we don't
allegation bro yeah
it's literally not an allegation why
don't they just be like we do not
support you
girls and so they're like in light of
recent allegations we're disgusted by
the allegations we're outraged no they
say
in mutual respect and loving adoration
we have
we have decided amongst ourselves to
partner we have to be outraged when you
write so hard for someone that's like
an actual p word you have to be outraged
like like
no that that was a honestly it wasn't
even like
they i can't get over they say we have
mutually we have agreed
morphy and james have agreed [ __ ]
what's the what's to agree on
[ __ ] dumbasses ah
so there there's obviously some
tenderness between them now james put
out again
also they issued their statements at the
exact same time which means they were
coordinating which is weird okay
they both put them out on twitter at the
same time so james put out a statement
this really [ __ ] my tits
can i say that this really [ __ ] my tits
off
you get in the mask and you become like
a different person you're literally like
somebody
[ __ ] my tits give me another slogan down
what does she say
somebody lick my [ __ ]
it's party time p-a-r-t why
because i chat's out oh it's because i
got a star there
because i gotta prt somebody tweak my
nipples
oh my god it sounds like you have actual
tourettes i know i always bring this up
but it does sound like gift threats when
you're
screaming like that somebody [ __ ] my
[ __ ]
somebody pee in my butt oh my god don't
wanna get to monetize stop
okay here's james statement you're right
family friendly jack black
think of that right we're family
friendly somebody
spit my [ __ ] and [ __ ] me
it's the mask it's not me it's the mask
not cute give me something cute to say
hold on hold on that sounds more
perverse than anything i just said
hold on sugar daddy somebody's got a
sweet tooth tonight
that looks like and i just say pineapple
for dinner if you get my drift
that looks like us can you pop that
photo look that's us look how dark my
face looks
i need like i need like lots of light
yeah you need like a glam core light
like right in front let's take the hat
off
no oh my god no i like martian now that
looks crazy
somebody's saying that more like that
but it's just
there's so much shadow that's fine
somebody stop me
that's pretty good okay somebody's
here let me do it so this is just sir
somebody stop me
yeah that's kind of good wait the teeth
the freddie mercury teeth i
like one day we should can we come
dressed as our favorite friday mercury
sure i want to be i want to break free
party freddie mercury i want to break
free
it's just big teeth that's all that no
he has the he's in drag in that one with
the pink outfit and the thing i want to
come did you say drag
drag it sounds like you said drag you do
have this rite aid freddy mercury and
you should
rite aid whatever i did i was like he
worked for writing
live aid live whoa he works for a rite
aid crazy i made freddie mercury's just
wearing a
like a white tank but he has the short
hair i want to
break free the armband and you know what
because there's a trend on tick-tock
right now i see a lot of people do it
they're like i'm dressed as
you know king tut trisha or i'm dressed
as birthday cheshire there's like trends
now where you dressed as like a version
of that person we could be
the versions of freddie mercury i love
him
i'm down i love my freddie mercury
should we get robbie malek to guest
judge that day to see who's the better
freddie mercury
i thought we don't like grammy malek no
we're we're oh we do like
why are we not like him what happened i
thought we thought he was pretentious
no i think we agreed with him being like
oh you got to set boundaries with people
okay you want to read this statement
will he be on to judge our friend he
will 100 000 billion percent be
on as well as brian mays and any
surviving member of queen will be here
yeah brian mays he's the guitarist
just may dismay just brian brian may's
here
you know a wedding they'll play your
wedding for like fifty thousand dollars
no they won't i'm talking about my
wedding please she got backstreet boys
for twenty thousand dollars for
someone's wedding because i'm trying to
get
the backstreet boys or watch the black
cop you're talking about queen here the
queen was like adam lambert
adam lambert's not coming with your
wedding for 50 000.
no [ __ ] way she told me she there's
village people will do it for 20
000. exactly village people's 20. my
wedding is gonna have the most random
entertainment 180
000. now that i know you can book people
like donna summer will come to your
wedding and perform i was like this is
she can get john mayer my wedding player
is kind of epic she should show she
mentions john mayer
i think if he comes acoustic with just a
guitar he's like 100k
i'm not showing up to anyone's wedding
for any amount of money i'll tell you
right now okay baller
i'm just saying it's just odd i'm not
i'm just it's just i love it
i'm not going to your wedding i'm trying
to get donny osmond in my
romance maybe just like donnie osmond
that's got to be a cheap buy that's got
to be a bargain i know he's really
popular he's like
yeah he has a vegas show and stuff he's
i love donnie osmond i'm trying to get
an elvis in person here my favorite
elvis impersonator just died trent
carlini i don't think you'll have any
trouble getting an elvis impersonator
no i want sean klush but he's really
popular he's booked all the time i'm
trying to get elvis
i'm trying to get all these people to my
wedding your sh your wedding's just
gonna be like a las vegas
that's what i wanted to be and i told
her that can we have like a las vegas
show why don't you just get look-alex
instead of the real celebs
that would be awesome
look like yeah i would get a queen a
queen tribute band i would
if you guys hey message me if you're a
tribute band or a tribute artist message
me we're trying to get michael jackson's
phone
yeah but i want real donnie osmond i
would love real mike i would pay my life
savings for my chemical romance their
tour just got postponed to 2022
i would give my life savings right now
to my wedding
how much how much can you pay seven
figures
oh wow seven figures my chemical romance
i love seven figures but yes
yeah i don't think they would do it i
think they're pretty cool he has an
umbrella academy he's busy but
hey the offer is out there i have seven
figures from my chemical romance all
right you want to read this
thing from james yeah nine million nine
hundred ninety nine thousand
yeah to look less sus when i transfer
would you say that
yeah you paid nine million nine hundred
ninety nine thousand dollars nine nine
nine nine
like i'm a roman saved my life so okay i
guess they deserve it they deserve it
okay here's james you know i'll just
give it to them they don't have to
perform if you want the money
here's the check give me your address i
said well what do i i feel like
you know you i feel like you bring me up
a lot that like i helped you a lot so if
you want to
give me your money i'm open to taking it
too
oh you want money yeah i'll take your
money seven figures
no he didn't save me that much all right
put me in your well at least give me a
cut
i want to cut your only fence i gotta
give some to joe rogan
i know sounds like he deserves some cut
in yeah you sent him some nudes get his
email and send him like he's squirting
unsolicited
hey big boy i knew you wanted this
big boy small boy ah
you just made fun of him we can because
he invited that he protruded small deck
energy we're allowed to acknowledge edit
commentary joe rogan is built like a
human thumb
no you can't say that he didn't come for
you
he came for me but i guess you're
defending me okay i don't know whatever
he's like a thumb with muscles thumbs
are hot
we love thumbs up okay here goes james
hi sisters
accountability is something that i've
spoken about a number of times in the
past
am i should i keep reading it like that
maybe not
in my most recent video i spoke about
and took a
accountability for my part in
conversations i had with a few
individuals who told me
they were over the age of 18. uh let me
rephrase
let me rephrase that i took a response i
partial no he took i took accountability
short of turning myself into the
authorities with individuals who were
under the age of 18
right let's just phrase rephrase that
instead of trying to pass the blame back
onto them
and off of you yeah individuals told me
they were over the age of 18.
okay they didn't someone said i
he goes that's still illegal when they
said they were 17 or 16 or something and
he acknowledged that oh it's still
yeah that came out after this video that
was like one of the torrents of action
before
yeah as i said in that video i can't
show change overnight but i will
uh over time some since posting that
video many other people have come
forward with a series of misleading
stories and false allegations which have
been reported on
by many people creators and news outlets
my legal team has begun taking action
against those that have spare
spread misinformation and or created
completely fake stories
and this as this has gone on too far
okay you [ __ ] piece of dog [ __ ]
you really gonna come out here and start
threatening like victims coming forward
let's say there was one that the dude
admitted to faking
so james tell me how many of them are
real and how many are fake you're
telling me that all
17 are like all i think there's like 12
miners uh don't quote me on that but
it's somewhere in the neighborhood
neighborhood of 12. so you're telling me
the 10 additional people that came out
against you
the miners they're all fake except for
two that he admitted to
except for the two you meditate all the
ten that came out with receipts are all
fake
okay two is too much anyways to even put
that on there now because he's just
trying to deflect and be like oh they're
not all drew it's like no
you did you did it twice you already did
it twice
delete yourself from social media for a
minute maybe i love how it goes this is
all gone on too far
[ __ ] don't you think you flirting with
miners was you going too far
over and over and over for years and
years and years don't you
don't you think sexting with miners has
maybe gone a little too far not the
people are
coming out against you you [ __ ] dip
human this is someone who needs to
outsource tonight beyonce if he's
desperate like he needs to find
a moroccan man to come over i i don't
know man he would do terrible things to
that poor
person over here for the visa he would
like i don't want him
i don't want to i don't want an
immigrant under his possession
you know what i mean i hear you he just
needs to go
live in [ __ ] rural like he just needs
to go
live on a farm somewhere away from
society yeah he needs to be like locked
away
um i just can't get over that line my
legal team has begun taking action
against by the way nobody has a legal
team what the [ __ ] does that mean dude
[ __ ] people always try to act all tough
my legal team what do you have like five
lawyers just on standby all the time
nobody has a legal team
no you have a lawyer disney has a legal
team a disney
legal team james charles does not have a
legal team
[Laughter]
and if he did he would not be like in
this position right now he would be like
better served james charles legal team
is like his uncle that
passed the bar a few years ago but
doesn't practice regularly
you know what i mean my legal team has
begun taking action against those that
have spread misinformation and or
created completely fake stories as this
has gone on too far
so what he's doing is there's probably
maybe one or two that are like fake or
exaggerated
and so he's doing a like a what's this
fallacy called dan it's not
is this a straw man i don't know if it's
a straw man but he's definitely like
it's like a
red herring or something he's basically
being like these two
lied this is out of control and i'm
taking legal action
no comment on the other eight deflecting
yeah deflecting out what he did
and it's gross like uh why did he even
put this out also intimidating people
that would come forward later
he's basically saying hey if you want to
come forward i have my uncle who passed
the bar seven years ago and hasn't
practiced
that might send you a legal letter
probably not that's what all these
people rely on though is this like
scaring people like i have money i have
a legal team and they never do anything
never even these big people that are
trying to sue me they'll send like i'll
i'll give him my lawyer's information
i'll be like i'm not taking it down
here's my allergies
and they'll send a letter to my lawyer
which cost me 600 to receive because
lawyers like will charge you to receive
a letter or whatever and then they don't
go any further
because like what are you going to do
like i can i can't have an opinion
and also just from a a optics standpoint
you going after someone who's come after
you legally it's
not is just gonna add fuel to the fire
it's like it's a loss loss for james too
even threatening it is just absolutely
corny but he's he's making that risk
to his public image to deter further
people from coming out that's really
what he's doing here
also what does that have to do with
morphe
like morphe's cool with this being
thrown in with their
with their morphe sounds like a piece of
[ __ ] though with their apology there and
they took so long like they sound like
they are they're peace and love and
mutual adoration and a heavy heart
we say goodbye to the prince and our
dearest friend and our best client
we love you forever james morpie's
losing all of their clients because
they dropped jeffrey shane like now it's
uh
uh james maybe so they're probably like
[ __ ] we need some money
you want to make them out uh a palette
not with morphe
anyone out there who got makeup hit us
up someone made a frenemies palette did
you see they they d
they disheveled the conspiracy palette
they put frenemies over and then they
put like titles like it was really
clever
we should rip off james because remember
how he got all butt hurt
about what someone ripped him off or
like rite aid or someone ripped him off
we should rip his pallet off and sell it
i mean he literally ripped you off
though
exactly that would be like the best
revenge if we did a collab with morphy
but it was just his palette
that would be the best and we just
called the [ __ ] james charles
palette um yeah i'm down
maybe not [ __ ] i'm trying to set up a
tesla giveaway to dunk on david oh are
we doing that
it's in the works okay with
uh we're working with this company i'm
trying to get it so we can do a tesla
giveaway
slash sponsorship and then give money to
like uh
we already raised a lot of money for the
uh sexual violence
thing what's that rain i don't know what
is it at dan i haven't checked it
right now unless it was at 50k about
but um i thought that would be uh poetic
to give away tesla yeah just shy of 50k
yeah we love that should we give away a
pink and a black tesla
um i don't know
it's kind of dope but at the same time
it's kind of hard to ride but it's dope
too
do you still have your tesla yeah you
should go find addison ryan park next to
her cause she has a pink tesla you guys
could be the new frenemies
she just got a ticket she got pulled
over and hollywood fix got her and she's
in a pink tesla
yeah i'm not i'm not looking to hang out
with addison ray not about it
no i hear you so you know britney spears
i know i'm just kidding people come for
me for it honestly i just got heated
that day i apologize i get really heated
sometimes sometimes i'm like whoa
you know i start seeing red what about
addison yeah the
brand new stuff i went a little off but
i want to talk about that but here let
me finish this
i apologize i always have to i just want
to apologize to everybody a paul
a blanket apology a blank check
apologies
you can sign that and catch it for
whatever you want anyone listening
apologies because i like that people
like me right now i'm trying really hard
to just
stay good and stay positive and i'm so
nervous i'm gonna know
i know that feeling bro trust me i i i
know that one day it's just gonna crack
because i
i feel like i've always been the same
person and now people like me like i
don't know what to do because i feel
like i've always been this person and
now i'm like oh my god
well you're better you've been good and
you've been like
i'm just kind of more mature about
things and i mean i'm supposed to be at
32 like what am i supposed to just be
you you would expect that you would grow
the [ __ ] up a little bit right i mean
yeah i guess not everyone in the 30s are
like that
i was pretty much i mean i i was
definitely a late
mature i could see that you know
i feel like i wasn't fully matured until
honestly like the last two years to be
totally honest guys
they say are like literally like 10
years behind girls maturity-wise looking
back on myself i was
i was just painfully immature for the
majority of my life you know
but you've been i don't say you were
problematic more so in your 30s than you
were in your 20s
not problematic but more controversial
and you're 30 yeah
yeah less controversial but i still i
mean i'm 34 now so
i don't know i was still doing dumb [ __ ]
in my 30s
yeah but i feel like in the past couple
of years i've matured a lot actually
yeah
ever since theodore was born oh oh
you agreed dad dad what yup yeah yeah
i fully agree i think becoming a father
matured you significantly
i've seen it over the last couple years
i mean yeah well there was a big
there was a big difference back in the
day in our early podcast days
that she was a nightmare kind of jack
black wasn't getting started it was
really good i watched it on friday night
i love him weren't they great that was
one of my favorite episodes can we get
him
maybe we might be able to because
apparently his son is a fan that's how
that we hooked that whole thing up his
son is really cool
he's probably he's yeah because if he
like loves david like all the david says
hate me i don't know that he loves david
i don't know that either but you know
what he's a body positive king maybe we
need him to like give us therapy like dr
drew like how are you so positive king
i want a burger and french fries right
[ __ ] i don't love
and he's so anyways i just love him
i know i look like him if we order pizza
something terrible going to happen
it's not temp fate ooh pizza because
then i kind of want to tempt fate
i want to prove to the world that we can
order pizza and nothing terrible happens
to us
the problem with your places and pizza
doesn't deliver here you have to yeah
yeah
yeah
so annoying because i'm moving i'm
moving can you
new house by the way about 15 minutes no
okay so wait
let me finish this if you got stuff do
you want to touch on remember
we have to keep it to two hours for
youtube this is with peace and love we
would talk forever if we could but we
have to
know we haven't seen each other in so
long well we can hang out afterwards
people go i want to watch
when i go afterwards i go let's go
upstairs and hang out in the backyard
people go i want to watch i think that
might be over saturating them
yeah let us hang out let us let us have
a moment it's not that exciting for what
it's worth no we just sit there and we
kind of just sit there quietly it's dead
air
no we we should move we have a post-show
wrap-up yeah we wrap it up
that's what impossible calls it but like
after our pro show meeting
shut up you're not that serious how did
it go everybody what can we work on for
next week
okay guys i think impulsive can improve
his podcast by not pre-filming at six
months ahead of time
that's my recommendation
um so he says these stories have caused
many of my long-term partners to receive
considerable negative feedback as they
should dumb [ __ ] piece of dog [ __ ]
[ __ ] face pony lover
i mean he's such an idiot it's fine they
can't flag you if you say that
we'll see i've got tourette's oh right
tourette's sorry
that then they just are uh i'm sorry
ethan i'm so sorry i'll
make sure to include it ableism one of
them being
morphy yeah dumb i've loved every moment
working together i love how he goes from
threatening his v
his victims to being like i love morphe
i love working with them
i'm beyond grateful for what we've
created together that said i reached out
to them it was me
by the way it was me that wanted to
sympathize not morphy
sure just want to kick them on the way
out be like yeah these guys are
pieces of [ __ ] don't support them that
being said i reached out to them and we
mutually agreed to wind down
our james charles ex morphe what would
this wind down business what are we
winding down
what does that mean just sell it to ross
and get it out ralph's
ross ross could it have been a um
contractual thing that like yeah dude
every contract has claws for if you
[ __ ]
essay a child they all have like um
um clauses for like miss uh
misconduct yeah fair enough
i think they just have a shitload of
merch and they're being greedy
they had just reordered right before the
scandal happened we're winding down
which is my only way
which is my only project with them i am
continuing to make time to learn
grow and listen except unless you're
accusing me then i'm sending a legal
team
i'm not listening to them i'm attacking
them
and i'm looking forward to coming back
one day in the future with a better
version of myself please don't ever come
back maybe in a few years did you watch
the jake paul boxing match
or do you want to talk we don't have
that much time so we have demi lovato
and we have um
addison ray
i don't know i didn't know there was a
jake paul fight so i'm going to skip
that because i didn't know anything
about well he just knocked out this dude
in like 10 seconds it was really lame
jake paul um demi lovato mad because
sugar free god she's so out of touch
so let devi lovato who really is so
annoying i don't know anything about her
except this post
her documentary was great and like you
know everyone was on her side because
she struggles with drugs and you're like
okay this is like good but now it's like
okay yeah we all got struggles lady so
uh dem demi lovato lovato
lovato she said i'm finding it extremely
hard this is some karen ass [ __ ] to be
honest
yeah i found it extremely hard to order
from froyo from this place
when you have to walk past tons of
sugar-free cookies and other diet foods
before you get to the counter do better
what is she what is she mad about
diet culture vultures what is she mad
about she's mad because it triggers her
because she had an eating disorder
okay so what the world needs to organize
around but like so what get the diet
food i don't understand the issue no
she's saying she diet food should not
even exist because it's promoting like
eating disorders and telling people they
need to be skinny
but you know there's diabetes diabetic
people need [ __ ] sugar
sugar-free desserts dumbass you're not
the only person
what's wrong with not wanting sugar i
don't get it she also promoted teami
which is a detox tea
which is like try to make you lose
weight fast by you know oh that's good
yeah so she's also so that's good
there's a photo of her with her little
tee her little dude what is wrong with
you well the problem is that she tagged
them like
do better please i don't even know what
the [ __ ] you're on about but now all of
her flakies went and disliked bomb this
poor wrestler
what oh that's that shitty like it's one
thing to have like an opinion about it
but also
well she tagged them and so now all over
[ __ ] [ __ ] fans
though like you said people oh there's
more she says so i think i'm gonna have
to make the hashtag a thing
oh no karen karen lovato
i will be calling harmful messages from
do you know what diabetes is
you dumbass there are more people in the
world than you
yeah it's not like diet pills it's like
sugar-free something because
it's way worse than [ __ ] sugar-free
treats i drink diet coke you want to
[ __ ]
you want to lynch my ass like diet coke
firing squad they have diet coke in
their entrance
i mean if you're trying to diet maybe
you should be drinking diet and not
whole coke anyway i don't see what's the
problem i actually personally love the
taste i will eat a whole large pizza
with diet cup i love diet coke
like i love the taste i'm not doing that
pizza
we can you want to order some are you
curious if i can rip this off
you want to do it but doesn't you want
to do tick tocks oh right
put it back you can definitely rip it
off by the way
somebody stop it it would be satisfying
we got to do tickets i know it would be
satisfying to see i love seeing people
pull it off
um afterwards okay so she says blah blah
blah
when when that coke is [ __ ] making me
hungry
sorry that was mean
yeah i'm sorry i think it's i think when
you mock
people like yeah you're right i take it
back but she's being such
so annoying yeah this is really i will
be calling harmful messages from brands
or companies that perpetuate a society
that do not enable but praises to sort i
don't know what she's even taught i
don't follow her logic what's wrong with
having diet food
i literally don't understand her logic
what is wrong she's saying i guess it's
yeah
what am i missing triggering her so i
think she's like upset about it but
because you know if you say if you pray
someone's weight loss some people
could say you're praising you know
skinny and like giving people eating
disorders but this doesn't make any
sense because she's like i don't get it
right dan what am i missing are you
understanding no
no no no i don't really i don't
understand no this is this is okay so
outrageous pills and diet culture is bad
because it's like you have this pillow
that's unhealthy and be skinny but the
sugar
sugar-free cookies you dumb [ __ ] yeah i
think i think there was a different way
and also when you have millions of
followers like dunking on like some
small business
like that who could be saving people's
lives like diabetics and stuff like that
tagging them anyway here i don't know
she's so upset at that
she's like trying to ruin their business
because they had like diet cookies i
mean we are not oh sh
they responded to her we are not diet
vultures
i don't know that's just a new thing
vultures are not
on diets by the way they eat everything
if your ass want to be a vulture you
should not
vultures eat everything you should know
that
[Laughter]
they eat sugar-free they eat sugar they
don't give a [ __ ]
they're vultures we are not this so this
is the poor little
store that's trying to defend themselves
they go we are not diet vultures
we cater all of our customers needs over
the past 36 years we are sorry you found
this offensive
and she's like [ __ ] i'm about to clap
back
she said not just that your service was
terrible okay
okay so it's not the diet cookies the
service was bad
can you just shut up can you just mind
your own [ __ ] business
jesus christ you have to complain about
everything inconvenient in your life
why is she the most annoying person
alive i liked her i watched her
documentary
i really liked her i felt for it now
this is like what i'm good at i guess
not just that your service was terrible
so rude the whole experience was
triggering and awful you could carry
things for other people while also
caring for other percentage of your
customers who struggle
daily just to even step foot in your
store
look if you got an issue don't go in a
candy store what the [ __ ] frozen yogurt
shop i think
okay whatever you can even
you can find a way to provide an
inviting environment for all people with
different needs including eating
disorders one of the deadliest diabetics
they're doing diabetes don't exist
forever one of the deadliest mental
illnesses
only second to opioids okay victim don't
make excuses
just do better i literally don't even
know what she's complaining about
but she thinks she's really doing
something here that's like i know
she goes since you all want to keep
going tags them again geez and they're
like apologize and they were like
i'm really sorry please you're and then
so here's all these points
from her dumbass fans provides toxic
cultures and extremely unprofessional
management
never visit again i don't know what they
did wrong
they have one star now literally her
initial point was just sugar
sugar-free cookies like what this place
is very triggering for people with
eating disorders
why their packages truly just see even
her fans don't even know what they're
crying about they says their packaging
is disgusting do not recommend
like what's on their packaging a big fat
person was shoving cookies in their face
and being like
triggering for eating disorders because
like a lot of people who can't eat or
our fear are getting fat they eat
sugar-free things and that's all they
can eat so they're
trying to eat something eating
sugar-free yeah what
oh [ __ ] somebody
spit my [ __ ] oh my god
you need to mind i was like i'm the mask
okay
horrendous service god these people are
so annoying demi lovato
you you win douchebag of the month yeah
for sure
it's just like why this is another one
of those things where people are like
being thrown off excavators that's
something to complain about maybe not
sugar-free cookies you know there's like
other things in there
stop throwing people off excavators
excavator vultures
yeah because when you're saving that
makes more sense because when you become
a cadaver and you [ __ ] your eyes
popped out of your head a vulture will
come and eat
but they will not vultures will eat
sugar-free cookies
i guarantee it
anyway that's all so that's about it oh
we have 10 more minutes dan
we have the ad reads some
pre-calculating that in
we got a pre-calculation eh
i feel like a different person today
it's so weird somebody
it's like when you're in costume you're
like so much funnier i don't know maybe
you feel more like comfortable i don't
know it's like weird every time you're
in costume it's like such a better
energy
i love it so scary
you know i look like jim carrey a little
bit
what's more catchphrases dan i didn't do
them all and did like three of them
i mean some of them on this list i don't
remember at all
what's that one what does that say no
hands
look mom i'm roadkill what that's
something [ __ ]
you know how hard it is to find a decent
man this isn't even a quote from him
this is like some somebody else in the
movie name's
hold me closer ed it's getting what the
[ __ ] the books are so dumb i'm just
saying you can't make
the scene if you don't have the green
there you go that's
that i can relate to you you can't make
the scene if you don't have
the greed edit you into the user
i apologize for that every time
what's number one now that you have to
ask yourself the question do you feel
lucky that's a quote from another movie
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah that's uh oh my gosh third mask
movie
well how are you gonna say the number
one quote from the mask is a quote it's
a quote from another movie i mean this
is just some
much shitty ass website crap yeah it's
garbage tourette's are strong
stop it it is because you can't control
it you literally
you know you don't know that anything i
know because you can't stop i'm like
okay stop bringing monetizing just keep
going with that bottom
cause it's funny stop you're out of line
you're out of line all right um
jake paul is a piece of [ __ ] did we talk
about that i literally didn't even know
anything that's happening this weekend i
went on to twitter and someone's like
jake paul he he he challenged this
boxing guy who's like
he was like out of shape hasn't fought
he's not a boxer he's a wrestler
ah and he it was just such a dumb do you
think he'll wrestle me
you want to wrestle the guy that lost is
he a wrestler he's a wrestler
do i know what's his name it's uh ben
ass
cheeks ben ashtreeks he was olympian
he was an mma fighter as well yeah well
he got his ass beat by jake paul in the
first round
literally knocked out in under two
minutes oh oh right because he was paid
or something right everyone's saying he
got paid to do that people are saying
he's paid
it looked a little sketchy but i don't i
i watched it back from a lot of angles i
mean that was a real hit
but i don't know why the ref called it i
just found that the obscene
you know what i thought i felt that
[ __ ] long for that
you watched i watched the whole i
bootlegged it
i powered it i felt like uh
i felt that way at first too but i saw a
different angle i mean the
the ref told him to uh you know how they
have him step forward or whatever
he was stumbling around it was probably
the right
given more time i mean like dude i mean
it's a show
fight like we're all right spent four
hours waiting for this dumbass fight i
didn't
we were watching dressing the [ __ ] cats
and eating tombstone pizza tombstone
mm-hmm
with oregano dosing the [ __ ] guts
though like the old one yeah
that movie rocks i love it yeah i love
tombstone
you know why they call it tombstone
because your fat ass is gonna die
well i don't know why else they call it
tombstone they're like you're gonna die
from
i think like the movie tombstone why
would they name their pizza after a
movie
a western movie pizza that's got nothing
to do with people they ate pizza
well they didn't i never saw it i've
seen it i love that movie
you have is michael madsen in it who
michael madsen no
no he's in one of those fighters in it
and he's really good
we should get back on the show he was
batman val kilmer was really good in
that
he played doc holliday we should dress
up as our favorite batman and have val
kilmer judge us
our dance our competition that's easy i
could set that up
get right on it i apologize for pushing
you to have a conversation with me about
wrestling
when you weren't comfortable with it i i
i hold no grudge
i will stop having conversations on the
podcast i will only be
but speak when spoken too yes please
like a good uh debutant or whatever
i don't know i think you're gonna say
something kinky like a good little girl
no i do want it daddy
here's the ethan version of the mask
daddy
daddy daddy all right that's it
we did it daddy
oh we gotta clap out today
you know
guys this has been frenemies you know
we're the only podcast in town
that we'll put on four hours of makeup
for no reason
i love it for sure we're the only
podcast that does that for sure
so we could say that if people start
doing that then you know they're copying
us
copyright lawsuit you'll be hearing from
my legal team
yeah my brother who failed the bar exam
but still can download pdfs with legal
cease and desist and fill in the blank
you'll be hearing from my legal team
i think we're the first podcast to do
like male female that didn't like each
other like let's start a podcast with
someone i don't like
has there been podcasts with people that
don't like each other no but people are
trying to now i listen to comedians
sometimes and they're like i'm trying to
find a girl to do a podcast with like
guy comedians and i think they're trying
to
they're trying to take this brilliant
formula that we've created of
of hating i'm curious if that works
because i feel like i would never expect
it to work but i just feel like we have
really good chemistry
well we were kind of forced to too
because moses right like we have a
mutual connection forever so we might as
well monetize it
oh yeah monetize everything always
i would have done this without if moses
wasn't involved i feel like no
no that's not true you didn't talk to me
before and then when moses and i
officially started dating you're like oh
something about this was like
months we were thinking about we wanted
to do a podcast with another comedian
and i brought your name up dan you could
testify
before you guys were dating but you
never talked to me ever like we never
had a
private conversation he's just saying
that the seed of the idea already
existed
where you guys were really but it didn't
come to fruition ever and then i was
like oh i did well there was just some i
don't know what it was but there was
it was an ongoing conversation like
she's here she's here to stay so
no that wasn't it i swear to god i was
just like you know what i really want to
make this
podcast and i really think trisha would
be great so let me ask her if she's
interested
and you said yes the rest is history
well i wasn't doing anything it was a
pandemic
yeah no it was a good time it was
perfect timing yeah we'll see how it is
after i get on snl
yeah no i think that would be a perfect
story arc where you just leave my ass
behind
no i wouldn't i feel like you're gonna
leave my ass behind i'm not going
anywhere i guarantee you that i got no
[ __ ] ambition
i have no ambition and i say that with
total sincerity
i said that i wouldn't take that spotify
deal from joe rogan and people said i
was kidding
people said i was being a clown i don't
think i would
yeah you you're very i don't care i
don't i have enough money
i mean i'm comfortable financially i
don't need a 500 billion dollars from
spotify
because it's [ __ ] up because then you
you're leaving out so many audience to
go
you know on spotify and then you and
then the my biggest nightmare about
going in with spotify
is that all of a sudden they have a say
creatively on your ship right
they deleted 40 plus episodes of his
because they didn't want that on their
platform
i do not want anyone telling me how to
do my [ __ ] show
and i will never mark my words
never bring anyone in
that will have any flex over me ever
now that said we got to wrap up the
episode because you two has to rate this
and so we have to hit a two hour uh time
limit
are you trying to contradict what i just
said i'll take the spotify
look i'm on youtube's platform i can't
make money
yeah platform youtube is kind of the
most forgiving of all
platforms so i'm realizing now yeah like
youtube's down for whatever they're like
you gotta do a lot to get banned on
youtube yeah you really do you do
you can do pretty much anything here
literally no one no one gets
kind of epic banned well i mean it
happens but like
it always it it's always like years
later like somebody's does something for
years and then
they finally get punishment iran this is
crazy
i hope you've enjoyed today's episode
i'm ethan klein
i am trisha paytas squirt champion
squirt queen undisputed guinness world
record holding squirkle that's right
i'm going on the joe rogan podcast soon
follow that i want i thought maybe he
would invite you after that
um down ready where is he in texas yeah
texas
yep yeah all right guys would you be mad
why no no i thought you didn't like him
i thought we're anti-him
it's complicated impulsive i can go on
or no
i would be more mad if you want an
impulsive then because joe broker has no
beef with you
i have no beef with joe i like i like
going on it
it's complicated it's like remember
facebook it's complicated i think he's
getting desperate for gas i think he'd
have me on
yeah cause nobody wants to fly to texas
to be on a [ __ ] show for spotif
anyway bye
[Music]
you